[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yo yo yo what's going on people might
check my check trucker hat hollow with
the finest super check each day we get
closer to the Hat Lord addict tips truck
ahead please use the CB radio turrets
and that's when you'll be wearing it yo
he lured you I got I got surprises for
you guys yeah let us go to audio sell we
got you got da me in a building you know
I'm saying we tell it right now we doing
a Mic Check waiting for King to come in
but I'm at them you cuz you know he
gonna break copyright strike cuz he's
gonna come in with some Raekwon beats
you go come in with some beat that's go
copyright strike this book from make
sure y'all get here was good just let us
know in the chat the levels is good that
was good
let us know your morning big Keith so
it's like Ice Queen gaming what's going
on Tallis the Floyd sounds can you hear
me fine yeah Chuck sigh yeah yeah at it
can you hit Dawg Dawg give him some bars
dawg get some balls on the top Mars bars
did you hear the bars
did you hit old that's what we need the
baby's high Mike said we good but what
was face every good random Bryce salute
so looks like everybody except me I mean
ours
no the PS Vita has never had any video
games bars Oh Oh easy
daddies wicked good games loose dude
that's not really wrong anyway we will
see out a bit we just wait no saw wait
no kid wait better about the popular
yeah bond everybody comes only new quick
before we lose is a copyright the
monetization
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh all right and we are live welcome to
the islands podcast and the Lords of
gaming dotnet episode number 160 that's
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about our special guests
and we've got PS 5 June 4th games reveal
Xbox series X compatibility news and
Last of Us 2 to discuss so we gonna get
right into it I want to introduce three
Lords even though to a president who in
addition to being our Bostonian brethren
from the north has always been an
absolute pressure to chop it up with and
each and every pack sees of it now that
these three laws consistently raised the
bar for creativity and what it means to
be gaming media they always find a way
to have some fun with a little bit a
degenerate journalism introducing first
my fellow IT brethren and the cleanest
eSport shoutcaster in the game
Lord solves invisible counterpart who
constantly reminds us what sob look is a
straight crook it's reducing second
everyone's favorite doctor and Lord
Kings official Caucasian doppelganger
the editor-in-chief of wicked and are
very old Heimdall holding the key to
second-floor alcoholic beverages
everywhere and last but certainly not
least the final part of the wicked get
Holy Trinity one of the best off the top
intro hopes and spit is in the game
fellow switch gang bro and super
producer of Spotify number one gaming
podcasts live from the state of
Massachusetts and for the first time
making their multiverse debut into the
realm of the Lord's my fale Lords crispy
dr. Bob and uncle doni of wicked good
gaming
how about bro story
[Laughter]
piece of unity we do is good Oh radio
babies we saw smelly Smith for the $10
to protest are you taste is lords of
gaming for neck ILP kos the last word
slow sous-vide Smith we got it we got a
say hey Smith yeah believe I got I got
it I got a question can you um I
continue correctly guess the next
statute that I'm pre-ordering
today oh if you can do that Smitty Smith
I got a t-shirt with your name on it and
listen you gotta say this is just for
Smith because he he he on the questions
um justjust you just got to tell me the
name of the character you don't even
gotta guess the complete statute just
the name of the character okay but you
get I think he needs some form of
entered the what you know what i'ma tell
you this he guessed the characters free
that's this guy maybe smith is a lord he
he is not I don't know
read my mom pretty tough for that you
know say we what we gonna get it to the
Gary but your first one rose doing oh my
god we got one where you actually
apologies to trucker hat holla yeah yeah
he actually has a person boots out of
the day with the flat ah so it's at each
day we get closer to the to the Hat Lord
attic tips trucker hat
use the CB radio ie Twitter to announce
that you'll be wearing it back that you
love the ones if I trucker hat your day
will how many likes we got a gift for
addict to get this at the truck we have
back with the two dollars of debt you
love to see it Lord semi-truck it's been
a while said they feel like eons man
since we've been a man this has been a
long year it's been a long year and like
it feels like PAX East was like two
years of one leg away yeah it was two
years ago it was all good just a week
ago it was okay I mean not even really
wasn't even good last week either but
like it you know it was it was all good
like three months ago and now everything
you know but uh no it was good it's
great to see you guys it's great to you
know you know be focusing on the good
out here and it's great to see you guys
here it's always always always a
pleasure and an honor to lake up so real
happy to be back and you know I'm
feeling good now you know I've got but I
was like halfway through my coffee and I
was like I'm starting to feel it a
little bit I hear the juices are flowing
and then the intro hits I'm about to
throw this out I don't even need it I'm
ready for whatever would you be plays
their game on
so I've been playing I actually just
reinstalled destiny to today that's me
too I like I basically don't know like
my ass from my elbow anymore with a game
I reinstalled it after like six months
off and I can't I don't even know what
to do so you guys I had to tell you like
you'll go to the UI look at because they
take everything that yeah yeah so I
reinstalled that I've been playing
animal crossing new horizons you know
gave me a 2020s which game but I've also
been playing a lot of Magic the
Gathering arena so I used to be a big
hearthstone guy uh ha stone got a little
too much for me but recently got into
some MTG arena so I've been playing that
a lot we actually just got up my first
like game play compilation on our
YouTube page of me not being
very great at that game I might know how
to play it everybody's been like Dom you
like one of the biggest nerds I know how
do you not know how to play magic but
now I know trying to go everybody can
get off my back salute dr. Baugh was
good oh brother what you've been playing
man what's up man it's been uh again
like Dom was saying it has been a long
time since we last met yes yeah I feel
like a little bro
in reality it's been legitimately three
months
uh yeah I'm doing good you know I
decided I wanted to have myself a little
Sunday mix myself a little mimosa
we got the most is on deck royal
beverages it's nothing fancy about it
either I just I need an ice water bottle
gonna fill it up two to three more time
it's been a long work we trying to think
what did I play what the hell did I play
this week I played maneater mm-hmm I
played uh yeah I string through that I
got to get a review up this week mm-hmm
I've been playing a bunch of dead by
daylight and then I tried out this
horror anthology collection mm-hmm that
they're raising money for Doctors
Without Borders it's called the dread X
collection okay it's a bunch of indie
horror games all created in like a week
and then I think a third of all the
money being raised for it is going to
Doctors Without Borders
it's super interesting but like the
infrastructure inside of the game is
poorly optimized so like you click on a
game and it takes you out of a window
oh crap my dream twice last night now
you know what I'm gonna focus Polly
loved the ma accents not a lot of
messages love a song we'll get some
chess when we get it to the Lord yes so
we got cat daddy liquid $2.00 super Jack
King getting that Jim Ryun statue fine
yeah that's the one what I'm doing I'm
Dan small
yeah different
and we got Smitty's move with the $2
uber chat lord King kitty pryde shout to
CB Grail twist the goat you know say my
brother CV great I say see lord Smitty
this is another classic example of king
stacking them stacking the cards his
favorite and I qui me give you a hint
yeah and they're not to mention it might
not even be from comic books I got I got
a good show radio I collect his comic
book character so it could be a master
cheap anybody got a baguette we can't
even get Marvel or DC no he already
already guess it's over oh we already
know we got the for those reasons it
already at the roundtable there brother
of another mother my co-host co-host the
difficult gave car Kura Lord of reviews
and the hop of the young wolf mommy Lord
addict are we doing sir doing pretty
good you know what's funny is I think
the only time that I play destiny now
it's here in the podcast it's a multi
tasking and I focusing salute look bad I
always have I'm the multi tasking keen
okay you can't get nothing by me the
only time I go a hundred percent in a
destiny is if you're talking about some
Nintendo switch stuff or something like
that that's the only time it cuz ain't
nobody trying to hear that so besides
destiny line with the podcast what have
you been playing sir um I've been
playing some Final Fantasy 14 okay I
have been and working late and I think
that that's pretty much I really played
a whole lot of games this week to be
honest with you but I did you know
finish up some of the little Vanguard
missions on tactics some of those those
are ridiculous that's wasabi I heard
about that
some solutes I'm sure the boss moves in
the buildings I would serve ILP Jamie
Genesis he said hey what final fantasy
about that you don't say so that's
pretty much it sir yeah but that's
that's about it no doubt no doubt
and of course we have our most technical
Gaming Lord the solo game over list for
the single player selfish experience and
also the sashka darkness
mr. offline profile Illuminati and lore
patreon of the iron bank nah man no and
sovereign how we doing sir was good
what's going on you see I I'm under the
table today look looking like the
unshaven gotta get a people would you
keep that up for a couple weeks off you
have people super chat and I gotta send
some love to my last word is some
destiny birthday first of all salute the
mister Aries in the chat that's my bro
so you still gotta take me to the
lighthouse sir but I'm not gonna let you
off dunk off that board Stadium wait no
you can you could take me to we would it
be that backpack for that lighthouse
gear but absolute to my bro the only
thing I want ready that whole time he's
carrying us is just doing emotes over
and I'll be ridiculous yo salute to my
bro see be grateful that's the man huge
lie that's the young goat right there
that's my do salute man good to see you
when I get to see you in the chest so
love or a nap but get back to solve man
what's going on what you've been playing
chilling over before I get into what
I've been playing on so we had a little
bit of UFC last night yes before white
night so the chosen one made his return
I would call people chosen to the
Octagon and it seems that God is not
with this I don't know he got chosen for
were chosen for this mic for the smite
yeah Tyron Woodley came back he was just
not you know like Hogg mentioned earlier
to me um before the podcast started he's
38 years old like he's not he's not
spring chicken he's not a young man
we've been through a lot of wars um and
I just don't think you know you get to a
certain point any fighter he's
young man but he can be an old vital key
qlw called him the frozen one
accompanied him and when you know he's
off in the in the Octagon
he's refreezes again he doesn't let her
go yup he doesn't pull the trigger they
have one who's men like yeah you look
the same
Gilbert burns up-and-coming young
brazilian fighter this dude is a beast
and just Pattaya
honestly I going in I was like all right
let's see we were Tyrone's heads faces
it is Wayne comes into the fight and he
was just not there man like he's just
not making too much rap music I remember
I saw his debut fight in UFC and he like
destroyed the other dude whatever reason
man he's just I was physically mentally
he's not there that's exactly what
happens he doesn't let his hands go and
he just looks chosen someone someone did
a salute to the Lord's and guess even
the corrupted one like the UFC last
night I forgot about what happened to T
would yeah yeah I know the movie what
happened to T would it kion inherits all
right P George Louis a [ __ ] recipe we're
calling for peace it's a lot a lot of
real things going on in the world and
really met it it's just that simple
peace that's really what it is get into
quickly what I'm playing um and you know
what I'm a sea Odyssey rabbit-hole
single-player selfish experience games
only selfish yes um so fun I'm level 70
well my god
7b and I'm pretty much through the story
part of the legacy of the first play DLC
so I have a few side little missions
that are part of the legacy of the first
play that haven't finished yet but the
main story I finished and it's
interesting like it adds to Achilles so
I'm either with most chemo
sound hemo she wants to play some dude
named Evo's my name is not demos demos
they call me Joseph I said what the hell
did I work his song or the VIP demos is
like that generic character that's in C
rated movies oh no Moses they may give
them right if you're not using them
right Sofia her name is not demos
Alexios name is demos right now you
using Alexios her name was demos Oh in
my game she's debo she's actually out
there Devo when people just mad cuz she
beat him a few times
let's stay focused solve yeah so I got
through that I'm anxious to finish up
what I would mop up what I have so I can
get into that atlantis dlc because i
heard that like the architecture like
the things you see are vastly different
to what you see in in the main game so
i'm excited to see that that's been a
pretty much pretty much it that's it
shelter for sale you on twitter already
know and of course we have the
incredible hulk of this AKA the XS gamer
ooh the lord of combat voice king of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement Oh beloved
Lord gig how we doing sir
Oh fantastic and for sweetie Smith let's
go boy you haven't seen Kos pleased Ock
with in true 4k 60 frames per second
unlike gen console that we know wait
wait I'm sowwy already doing this yeah
no I decided curiosity you guys showed
you all right so um let me see what I
was playing is we all right let me pull
up my game Pass turn the beat around
Smitty smoke the $2 super check that's
my man our playful banter is because he
be in there all right I don't know if
that says a bad thing about it but yeah
I beat my crab Dungeness we got a $2.00
super trap from gaming Forte say with me
everyone my craft dungeons table I
played with a Tim dog game and Forte in
Natick in minecraft dungeons now so them
for dragging me into something I ain't
have all my faculties Street was
literally the moment he joined that the
game and in German showed up like
literally the moment he joined I joined
in a boss showed up I'm not even level 1
I'm here bricks we killed the Internet
he loved with her three times
we've been squarely their real quickshot
he said the UFC should implement age
brackets damn what slander contain all
Bellator playing minecraft dungeons
definitely um also went back and back up
at our Alan wait oh that game is so hot
in fact it seamlessly you know allows
you to play the game in when you plan on
the X the way it up raises and does
everything else flawlessly is it's
amazing it's amazing
also I was playing Assassin's Creed
Odyssey ok I'm 110 I was in
I'm level 75 ma'am we talk about me
yes I'm not in I don't know I'm not even
close to UM to finish in the game on the
answer that was a shout-out to l-boogie
because she picked up the game I think
was last week is something like that for
like 24 hours you got all the DLC and
stuff and what I'm doing right now is
I'm going to each Island mm-hmm and I'm
going to all the question marks I'm
clearing out the island not not doing no
balance he's just killing up everything
that can kill cuz I'm just that animal
right now and I'm wearing armor of
Achilles every day I watch boom veni
vidi vici
I saw a not conquered so I'm on all
through it and I'm just living in the
law of what a Greek mythology I found a
couple of other places that I didn't
know existed it is this if this might be
oh I thought origins and I'm gonna keep
saying it oh wait wait wait we're
talking we doing go talk well I think
this is the game of our generation and
I'm only gonna say this this reason why
okay the level of the openness in the
world the fact that you can transverse
over sea land and you can't well air
basic when you jump in inside and
outside inside caves outside caves talk
to MPC's wherever however interact with
everyone on a different level you can
scale get everything in the game so when
you was loading that in in Zelda talking
about no no I must land in a day there
you modified and did it better okay I'm
just saying like we really have to take
a critical eye to this game because it
is beautiful
omelet from s to an X and love with this
game is representative on addict do you
agree fish what game artist is literally
like I have a very high opinion on RPGs
yeah and I would say artist sees on
Skyrim levels oh I gotta give it oh wow
I can go talk yeah yeah that's that's my
all-time favorite game
is Skyler I do like I'm the I I like to
clear out the map in every game no I
don't he games especially AC games and
this one was difficult for me I was
doing what Ken was all too big and then
I just I our fell off like I said LA
can't because the thing is that's my one
gripe with the game is that those those
missions yeah do become repetitive
because it does become like Oh like you
know if will trade just kill this to
everybody that yeah that that part gets
repetitive now the the landscapes
changed like I would not expect the game
this big to have landscapes that look
different and varied but they do go from
like a countryside to a swamp to that so
nice diversity to a mountainside it's
very the biggest thing I have an issue
with the game is is they look he tried
to to get you to buy double xp stuff
because yeah fluff the XP people could
say what they want they fluff that XP
the only reason that they I know they
flood that XP is because they gave you
the option to buy in XP boosters yeah
insulin time has taken me an entire days
worth of gameplay to jump on level well
I mean like six seven hours to just jump
one level while yeah that's crazy so
that's been all yeah I would like to
bend the knee to you guys oh this I
gotta Benny for this which okay I wasn't
mad a friend of mine mmm-hmm was like yo
um I need to get a switch you oughta got
it on eBay for 500 thing my daughter
okay
some like literally said animal cross I
said you gonna pay five hundred dollars
just for one game damas week yes and
listen the next thing out of mouth was
Mariel is the greatest game ever made
oh okay I said what your friend had me
so he said that
no but um okay I'm trying to process it
you know they did open up the factory
and again that the systems will be
available soon just you know born
Nintendo directly try to get a refurbish
yeah but the level of thirst the level
of thirst to acquire this because they
said our store got it and the fever for
this system
it's completely different than anything
I've ever seen
yeah it's different energy then you
couple that with the pandemic and people
and stuff like that I've seen it I
haven't seen it I don't even know how
the hell is doing it
I don't shout out this vide Smith he's
like salute to the Oracle ak8 Lord annik
I think he's onto something with AC
Odyssey okay oh really some Odyssey love
man that's was so man I've been pretty
much again right you know what a lot of
people try to say I've noticed is that a
lot of people try to go into scenario to
the only Xbox people like Odyssey I I've
seen this so a bunch of times because I
mean let's play that's cuz PlayStation
guys have God of War the superior game
think I enjoy SAS is great Odyssey more
weight you literally mean the room that
you gotta go in a fight the three
enemies this aside are you talking about
the time where you fight the same you
know boss maybe we're talking about
different god wars that's why we had a
double check talking about the original
trilogy - okay on the floor oh you can
play the third one
7:29 all I know is the first 30 minutes
I love God were 18 it was one of my
favorite games this gen but the first 30
minutes of god of war 3 is better than
the entire game of 2018 oh yeah but if
you play it on their regular PlayStation
go catch cataracts that doesn't mean
like both of them are amazing games I
just like the atmosphere that 3 had I
don't think there's ever been a game to
ever quite capture that atmosphere
nothing about the last God awards boy no
V Lord kognito sprint never listen to
Roman IOP now tell me what you want able
what you need to hear shout to fill
dominus pencil also finished gear
statics like myself this week guest
actors absolutely spending yeah this
this boss damage kognito so bad that he
is keeping up to date with other people
that beat this boss right that that boss
shang tsung me for a little [ __ ] that's
my stroll a little bit for a little bit
what's tax gift taxes was good yeah I
really want approach you like turn-based
strategy for first entry into the series
the gameplay mechanics very unique they
also have like it's overwhelming odds
all the time but they got this execution
mechanic that allows you to be able
again to kind of change the odds you
know I've already at nauseam said on how
I feel about the side missions I'm gonna
go into the side missions need lower and
I'm saying but as far as production
value and story you got you know Kate's
dad back in the day you know the whole
joint with the cog in the gears you get
narrative pieces you learning stuff
really really good can't wait for my
console brothers to get it is super late
I didn't write it um
you got ultimate yes Oh Dom even done
yeah yeah no I do I paying a dollar a
dollar for the whole thing yes that's
amazing who did definitely yes tactic
like like XCOM where if someone dies you
just lose your party member it just they
can't be a name character
when you look at the roster they'll have
main characters and non name characters
the name characters if they die it's
it's a rat like they before the mission
start they'll tell you these protect the
specific ones to the story cannot die so
if they die the missions over
right but also could recruit fellow
gears and you trading in this water and
if they die that's that's perfectly fine
I'll just have you have you have carmine
a through Z pretty much everybody's got
hope with calm eyes on deck there you
know what they didn't do that but they
should have done shot the cat daddy
played it on a harder difficulty broke
that difficulty down bro I'm telling you
right now you you said I had to take a
two-week break it straighter but I will
say is they got the best boss mechanics
of any turn base shoot interpreter press
game identity including hat on chemic
plan it's so I still think the chosen or
better
I think the chosen are better you for
their unique abilities and the fact they
can get crazy at any time and they can
pop up where they can really roll up on
you but they're like if you want stop
the boss fights in like the broom act of
adderall is crazy attacked look because
you you you should okay okay let's look
you we're not talking about going into
the boss mechanics mister shooting in
the front so he turns around then
everybody shoot him in the back it's
really why you're funny but is high it's
fire them tell you but that's just me
anyways what's the loot today I'll be
doing that shot that Mortal Kombat 11
after map the elbow playing whoa fire
high fire crazy story implications it's
what says about got like a good you know
two hours two to three hours of gameplay
direct continuation right after the
story for man it's it's crazy man only
haven't written yet I don't really wanna
got to finish 11 the hip attaches there
yeah it's a Robocop yeah oh yeah it
sounds of Robocop you get your Robo
conference interpreting on you know and
saying so that satisfy I was doing that
and on yes I think that was the oh and I
actually started off savile be proud I
started by single-player selfish
Last of Us replay everybody to a pawn
what's up yo say did you email or play
it the first time no I did but I blue
was funny I played it in 4k it is such a
difference in 1080p 60 like I was like
what was I doing why was that not doing
performance mode on a pro like what was
wrong it was made for ya cinematic
scenes they seem to be at 60 frames as
well it looks like it's a Weibull fluid
game shout out shout out to that man
that's pretty much it for bill shot just
show one mm which I hope he goes and get
real industry peeps now saucin saucin
Liu brother much appreciate it much
appreciate it Yuri know so now that we
got to what the Moors have been playing
and knuckled ami has already been given
the royal treatment before please check
I owe P 108 when he came in drop bars on
his tremendous game in history and of
course we don't have our boy Chris but
we got the doctor in the building dr.
Bob so to talk about his video game
system history his journey as a content
creator and what led him to becoming the
co founder and editor-in-chief of wicked
good games so dr. Bob would start from
the very beginning man what was some of
the first video game systems you had and
what got you into gaming jeez what a
question oh my god let's see I think the
FIR I think the first time I ever picked
up a controller was an SNES I think my
cousin's at it and then the first
console I ever owned was an n64 and that
was that was like that was like the
memory creator cuz I have two older
sisters and we would be playing till
like 3 o'clock in the morning every
night giving them games which I was
rocky we there was a lot of banjo a lot
of xyla attic is a brother for life
because the n64 is like I played like my
dad and stuff had the Super Nintendo but
like I never owned it because it was
always his unfortunately but like he
bought me an n64 when I was like 8 or 9
or something like that
he bought me Glover instars Rogue
Squadron I didn't understand
you know what's funny to this day I've
never be Glover Wow
Dex they were supposed to met they're
supposed to be making a sequel that's
man I want a sequel to Geoff force
Gemini goddammit that one uh arguably
with Microsoft owns that now you hear me
Phil so so when that happens you know
you're gonna have we're gonna have to
get out of public Twitter now who did
that for you have to do you have their
Justin by his real name that's Phil
Dominus Maximus Spencer soon to be
Aurelius you say you say this soon to be
Aurelius so much like what are you gonna
do after he's called really
I said that's when he don't conquered he
came and he saw but he's gonna get that
last name when he conquered that did it
doctor you don't say that the boss are
like what what so I guess you need 64 or
like this stuff you don't say it
so what else we were waiting from there
as you start so I would always end up
with a PlayStation console my other
sister would end up with a Nintendo
console and then my other sister would
end up with like the original Xbox and
that's what we had growing up that was
that was like the chain going up every
console generation one of us would get
one of them so we so we basically all
had access to it and then they got super
old they moved out and then so
everything just everything just came my
way went into the xbox360 got the red
ring of death like more time I have to
say that when it comes to you know the
host and port of the 360 think how bad
this console had people this thing was
breaking down and instead of buying the
competition it would go by before you go
hey Bob right back
we gotta pay the bills real quick you
got you got you got to get that man
Patrick Morgan
we got a $60 o $60 super chat addict I'm
gonna need you to take this money and go
by God award 2018 put on the hardest
difficulty and try again leave
Assassin's Creed obviously have a great
day Thank You Patrick I'm sorry but at
the end of the day just because you beat
something we're literally all there all
that difficulties let's just instead it
take you something to hit him three
times to kill we're gonna make you hit
him 15 and I don't I don't agree with
that kind of difficulty but you know
yeah boy just for you dough
I mean it's cool it's just for me but
ankle ankle doing I don't want another
that give me got a war none of that like
they trying to get kids smoother do that
was a great experience on normal I don't
want to give me daughter war smoke you
guys could cap that put that on Twitter
you could take a picture this is my I
don't want that guard or give me more
smoke all right thank you thank you
let's get focused now anyway back to
shake my head off obviously we took of
ratings yeah yeah so like you were
saying it's crazy how nobody wanted to
just get a different console but on the
third time I got the red ring I said you
know what maybe I'm gonna try out a
Playstation 3 and I did and I put the
only game I played at the time was
resistance to like I'm would you
legitimately I think I played through a
couple of the Ratchet and Clank games
and then just resistance to and then my
and then they shipped me back a new Xbox
360 I was like right all right I'm gonna
go play cod again whoa lot of Wolfie box
right there we should just cut the mic
weak it out
the power of call of duty doing them p60
don't tell me I can what I can't high
school days
talk tool all I'm gonna say is about the
red ring real quick is I feel like
especially for people in like our age
bracket you have like your coming-of-age
has like it's a part of it so the the
coming-of-age story American Fork in
here like you know you learn like you
learn your birds and the bees you know
you have your first kiss you you put
your hand on it you learn how to like
grip a football and throw a spiral and
you learn how to wrap your xbox 360
modena manhood right yes you know
everybody knew about the program gotta
get you serial number they said you to
box you had to wait to process the
process we live asked me so many times
people been like like my friends that
game they asked me like how long like
you know where cuz I just got married
last year some he's like you know how
long you've been with your girl for and
I was like she remembers when I had to
wrap my xbox 360 in towels that's how
long those are basically so when you got
the 360 back you kind of went back to
see oh do my stuff yeah no doubt and
then from there start the next
generation at that point you just
started picking up everything every
system that came out was there every in
any trip was there ever PC gaming for
you or no yeah so when I was growing up
I was big into FPS on PC okay FPS mmo's
runescape particularly okay but yeah
that's it was on the weekend all right
all right you said prints came out now
definitely we approve of this
I mentioned Cod I kick him out but yeah
it was like it was like weekend on the
weekends I was always playing like
runescape or as playing counter-strike
and counter-strike source 1.6 but then
during the week after school everybody
would go home from school and we
you play xbox together 90 percent of the
time from xbox 360 going into the next
console mm-hmm I got an Xbox one I
played it for I'm gonna say six months
and at that point I just said you know
what I'm gonna upgrade I bought a PC I
bought a gaming PC and that's what I've
been doing since and then from there I
haven't touched my xbox since oh yeah I
could do
I bought a PlayStation 4 instead because
there's so many incredible exclusive
games on PlayStation here's me vouching
again let's go there's so many
incredible exclusive games on
PlayStation that you can't play anywhere
else so I had to buy one for one Black
Friday it was like 200 bucks I got
spider-man oh yeah god of war and blood
those are console selling games Mac 2 is
revolutionary game listen I'm not gonna
lie he had to wait for that Black Friday
deal because he was never spend more
than that I mean considering came that
you you say you won't buy any other game
that's not on game fast can you really
say anything no literally I cannot and
you know and I applaud him and remember
that is my four one three man where we
are man I feel like 200 might have been
a little bit too much he spent it wasn't
too much that's that's a right price for
PlayStation $200 with all the games are
free yes shout to spitting Smith would
be a messy finally says shout out to the
UPS Store for his 360 typically think
about you yes was made cuz they're like
your Microsoft messed up and now we get
all this free business for no reason no
listen no lied oh they got that console
back to you so fast
literally well that equator I got my own
what they said that you know that a lot
of that funding that one billion dollar
funny to say
the 360 was for like two days shipping
yes continue Bob so at that point is
those exclusive no horizon zero dawn
that's what a rocket 505 and ask him
I haven't played horizon zero dawn yet
look the massive open world games like
you guys are just going on about
Assassin's Creed I can't play those
games famous because it's I would
literally have to go to every single
question mark on every single island
every single location to do that like
that just seems like you might need to
like like have that looked clearly this
is a clinically prescribed clinically
evaluated it's it's like severe OCD when
it comes to stuff like that like I tried
playing The Witcher this year oh that I
maybe got halfway through that game and
I did everything and I had to put it
away I couldn't do a food but yeah i
haven't played horizons are done I know
people in our community have asked me
the like you got a PlayStation of how
have you not played her eyes and you're
done yet you because I would have to
dedicate three months of my life to just
this game I don't know if I can do that
have you ever taken nyquil taken I quote
that is the equivalent of playing that
game that's we completely support this
message I actually didn't mind I always
I thought the story was great but after
a while I don't know I don't know I
think people get excited over like
robotic dinosaurs but I was like alright
whatever
like and then fighting them after Wahb
doesn't it just isn't that fun and then
the the human enemies aren't great every
father cut scene and you said no way for
the cutscene to go pass you just wake up
but what about real quick what about
that that last of us that did that grab
you in from oh I already have it on ps3
so you didn't need the beat I had a I
played through it on ps3 I got so when I
had I had my ACL surgery right
my xbox broke so I have my PlayStation 3
and I was binge watching The Sopranos
once a little and then one weekend so
I'm lying on my couch I'm in that Lake
I'm in that knee machine yeah for a week
straight and my sister bought me the
Last of Us
but you brought it over and I'm just
lying down and it's become it's become
one of my favorite games of all time
it's like it's probably I'm gonna say
number three not a list of like greatest
games of all time hold it hold it cuz
I'm coming back on that one we go get
that top five all right but I'm keeping
the balls right there so I got a speed
you up cuz again tremendous history
[Music]
bleed eggs I gotta shoot it you'll bleed
eggs I see it I see this laid eggs join
the realm so we can see it for real so I
gotta ask you this cuz obviously you
know say I bet you brothers out at PAX
it's always a good time and I'm saying a
little bit of origin story real quick
and I'm saying like the linking you know
I'm saying up this wiki good gaming
thing you know I'm saying so like
they're talking about like how that came
together and was it the site an auto
podcast first which one was first yeah
chicken in and the egg right there my
god I'm so Dom and I were playing D&D I
think it was like we were like four
years into playing D&D every single week
for like four years straight crazy at
this point yeah may no more than that I
was in college it yeah that time so
we're playing D&D
I grew up a Kris I've known Dom from our
home town and we're just sitting there
and one night we were like why don't we
do it like we talked about sit here we
talk about video game
when we come and sit down to play
Dungeons and Dragons mmm why don't we
like do something with it
hmm so he was Dom was working with Chris
at the time he reached out to Chris who
was the only person that we knew that
was capable of making a website Chris
was like Chris was like oh yeah man so
initially we wanted to get other people
we're playing Dungeons and Dragons with
but everyone was like now we can't
really commit to that so the three of us
were like I corrigan wasn't yeah we got
this okay and yeah we wanted to do a
podcast first but we came the unanimous
decision that it's let's generate a
following and possibly a community
through a blog site cuz you know it's we
could do that whenever they're doing
apart yes you get a structure it you
have to schedule everything right so
let's we could build something first and
then we'll do a podcast right we had the
blog signup I think it was like May 2016
oh yeah we missed our four year
anniversary by the way four year olds so
after like I think was like eight months
to ten months that we had the blog set
up we said I let's give it a shot let's
see what we could do with the podcast
and we've just been going ever since
yeah great now what we wanted to do the
podcast first okay okay so you did okay
I got you so why not another gaming [ __ ]
- I love the big Y that it did like you
got you gotta give me that now Bostonian
- wicked good stuff you don't say like
so naming conventions yeah have you ever
have you ever seen
Not Another Teen Movie okay all right
okay it's a white thing it's hilarious
watch it okay it's pretty much a movie
making fun of other like like romantic
movies like varsity blues gosh yeah so
it's we were going back and forth about
like what do we call like what do we
call the show cuz like wicked good
gaming well that just seemed like a
no-brainer because like if you're from
our area like Rick it is like give us
the town bars yeah yeah you already yes
so if you're from if you're from a route
our way you know you like
anything that is of exceptional caliber
you know we would say something is like
wicked good or like wicked ha yeah this
lobster roll this wicked good right so
you see like wicked hard or like oh my
god like I had a wicked long commute
this morning or like man you see in
there is yeah I mean it's just you see
you know that's the slang at at oh yeah
ok we got it good so we've you know so
wicked good gaming just felt like a
natural they felt like a natural thing
for like the for the blog cuz we wanted
people to know who we were even though
they couldn't hear our voices we wanted
to make sure that they could hear our
voices like through the written words
and we didn't have any sort of recorded
anything up you know when we got a good
amount of following just from like I
mean we we're kind of diligent about
like sharing stuff on our personal
social medias but like we got a good
following of people who were reading the
website that were from our area and I
was like I don't even know how you find
out about stuff like this so yeah we
were kind of going back and forth and
then when the podcast came around we
like when the idea for that was like
alright we have a good foundation now
you know we were consistent enough with
the blogs and and you know people are
starting to pick it up so now let's try
to get things recorded let's try to put
something on wax you know let's let's
let's get this you know the audio
content going so one of the first logo
ideas that I had was the exact cover of
Not Another Teen Movie it was like the
big like red block text I still have it
somewhere I wish I had like the old text
like going back and forth about the
logos and stuff like I probably have it
somewhere somewhere yeah so like not
another gaming podcast was one of the
ideas that came out cuz we were like
what are we doing everybody was just
like alright yeah this that just rolls I
might have to go watch not another team
in vain I've seen that movie it probably
five six years um so so yeah I mean that
was just that was one of the ones that
came up I still have the logo mock-up on
my computer but like hehe
yeah not another gaming podcast was born
and yeah it's like 183 episodes later
though
don't legacy continues and then I gotta
ask you like you guys are also the
staples of our PAX East is like linking
with our brethren you know say so like
how did you guys kind of incorporate
taxes to as part of your whole journey
like this is the thing for you guys are
the staples there wow I mean I think I
think we got invited to pax the first
year we created our website dome which
was like we we had no understanding of
it but I think they must have been like
reaching out to local games journalists
like outlets and whatnot and they reach
out to us we went we had no idea what we
were doing so we just went and we walked
around and we were we had no idea of
like setting schedules setting up
appointments and stuff like that so we
just straight up walked to every booth
it was like hey we got some in the chat
real quick no no no offense to anyone in
the chat but if I see you exploiting
last was to in the chat it's an auto
hidden yeah I'm sorry but that's just
how it is it might be all out of here
got that so cattivo
yeah I mean we went into it the first
year we had no clue what we were doing I
don't know how much I don't know how
much we got recognized that year but
then the subsequent year we don't know
yeah exactly the subsequent year we went
we had a game plan we were gonna go
we're gonna check out these games we're
gonna interview these people and like
surprisingly like a dozen people came up
with like oh are you the guys from
wicked good gaming yeah yeah exactly a
legitimate we're Haworth worth throwing
koozies off of people's hands
[Laughter]
yeah I mean we uh like pax has always
been like our home base we went out of
town once we did a Dreamhack Montreal
which was dope we took a nice little
road trip up north up even further north
and went to Dreamhack so that was really
cool I got food poisoning it was kind of
we have lessons to learn for the next
time we go on the road and we were
trying to do III this year and then of
course it's like just our luck man it's
just like a stroke of luck for us I have
where it's like yeah yes all right we're
finally ready to do III because last
year we wanted to do it and I was
getting married yeah yeah
got invited last year and it's like
Dom's wedding is like two weeks after
yeah
so that was just not gonna happen and
then so basically we like all fired up
and I was like guys this is it
I got a new nine-to-five I can actually
sock some money away we can get like the
accommodations real nice you know like
we can do a real big I'll rent a little
Corvette so I can drop the top with King
you know and so and then of course of
global pandemic it's and now we're stuck
at home yeah hey I wanted to salute you
brothers man love what you guys do love
the energy just a bunch of regular they
leave time out time out
you can't walk away without telling this
story Bob Bob which one
when we pulled up to the joint to the to
the ASA party tell a story Bob this is
this is when you big in your town and
they had a what can an unfortunate a
person who's going on is luck or
whatever right oh you know I had him off
with some braids now so no Paytas dude
yeah hey he a former boxer get his boy
some money yeah
so you know and we joking around and all
that stuff um we get in the line right
we get get into the front we all got our
badges on our neck and we like let's do
this yes sir
so when we get up there they have a
little scheduling thing and have to go
off of your invite right and uh shout
out to the young girl and Dom went up
there she was like oh we don't have you
on the list wicked good game
she's almost played ourselves
oh I don't see you on the list
yo shout-out to the older lady mm-hmm
that was on the side and said what
wicked good gaming yeah yes give them a
badge it was I got goose bumps know who
this is
she looked over like Kanye is salute
salute bags so it was it was that moment
and I and I looked over at Bob I said I
got it up real quick is Bob Bob story is
legendary and it says that prior year
right we go too fast I was gonna say
Freddy was its video losing in 2019 so
ASA party is definitely one of our main
things right we said did we get laid
without whatever so outdoor we was
balling I was like yeah we had a good
time no so I'll kick it even Bob I'm
right y'all didn't he was like but she
didn't go upstairs though very what you
really like I didn't even know there was
anything like that exists say hold on so
this year he opened up my whole universe
I was like oh this is how you live this
is how they do it
mr. hustle Oh hustle yes
so we did what Bob said yes and I told
them you know anytime you see the black
and gold yes we good shout out to my man
gene yeah shout the G here chat to you
know writer for IOP that's right let's
give a definite salute living his life
shout the foul though shout out the
bacio shot the ball you to change the
shot but yo shout out shout out shout
the G for leaving that whack party and
then teleporting to us with the
quickness as if he had a teleportation
device when he showed the picture it was
tumbleweeds we hear that
the pictures showing where we were I
cannae turned around he was like did he
say he's still drunk if you guys want to
come you want a party you want to get
drunk come with us your Dom salute to
the appetizers on deck for you yo salute
na yo solve you missed out brother
Oh a monopoly on the appetizers and
that's the thing too is like we and I
feel like this happens every time like
me Chris and Bob go out and if it's like
the three of us or if it's me and Chris
or whoever it's just like we like make
friends with the employees and then oh
my god we're just coming back to you
yeah we're just coming back over here
like you guys are unbelievable like so
we're just gonna and so we had like I
don't know if this was just like a
designated lane for the the server to go
through with the appetizers but they had
to come through us every single time and
it was like okay and I was like oh [ __ ]
the bacon dragon coming back over here
we just went and swooped down on it and
it was like all right I guess she's
going back to the kitchen again was just
for me but I just remember being
belligerent laughing at the Counter
Strike people wanting to get a little
challenge them it was it was a movie man
movies always good to see you guys here
brothers in talking game and have a fun
part on yeah man we go we go get it
moving real quick um I want to talk
about real quick that I've seen you
touched on it
you don't say as far as that last was
but I mean dr. Bob's top five video
games or franchises of all time all
right okay okay I can do this I can
definitely do this number one number one
Legend of Zelda Majora's Mask even say
Skyward Sword I was gonna clap
regardless I put me I put majority on
task over ocarina of time that's the
biggest question I don't I played it for
about 15 minutes and then I got you
would adding a rocket one three I'm
[Laughter]
alright Majora's Mask I think I gotta go
number two is Red Dead Redemption wall
solve is unique I'm gonna say I'm gonna
say one I consider it significantly
better than Red Dead Redemption -
granted redemption - looks better Red
Dead Redemption one was too
revolutionary for you solve the we
cosine you're Red Dead connoisseur so we
need to make sure that easily did you I
can assume you play through undead
nightmare the greatest DLC to ever be
really the greatest DLC literally the
greatest DLC can ever be released for
any game over that's fine continue I
would never know I love the guy he lost
his god he said Skyward Sword was in the
recycle bin so we could
that's a good thing I'm gonna go number
three probably the last of us I think I
think it's quite possibly the peak of
video games storytelling where you don't
need to fill changing the whole story
yeah you don't you don't need to focus
too much of the gameplay the gameplay
was fine but the actual story around it
was too beautiful to be missed three
number four Dark Souls the dirties
French arts crushing you oh my the dark
souls franchise has so happens when you
get people my age all saving continued
black souls has done things to my
videogame career that I like it's opened
up so many other genres of video games
that I could never expect to play mm-hmm
and it makes it like you guys know me I
like to brag about everything that I do
mm-hmm if I can beat every single Dark
Souls at every single from software game
it just boosts my ego even more I'm all
for it I feel that but can you beat it
off the guitar no of course people at
the planet thank you looking at all I
know is you ain't one of those pieces
could be the franchise as well don't
have to be a specific what to it could
be a fragile I think I mean it's between
counter-strike and Gears of War 2 mm
counter-strike is too influential for me
for when it comes to like first-person
shooting games and like it's basically
what brought me back into PC gaming
but Gears of War 2 was the game that it
was if I wasn't too young at the time
and I knew what professional gaming was
that's the game that I would have
pursued oh wow tell me arcade dad you're
gonna say attic definitely gonna walk
into his car after this
because they show you good to tell baby
you gonna make sure you say it's like we
gotta protect this one they've gotta
protect this was salute man let me get
these super chance real quick mocha
smiley turn on something chair anyone
else miss 1 vs. 100 from the 360 era I
remember that you know I'm saying give
me spinach please please please 60s
ancestors fight over here just to listen
to King going off on a fierce rivalry
over Xbox backing pad the book of X book
of Acts you gotta move this mother
already right yeah I love 100 I don't
know why they shut out to [ __ ] up okay
shout out to my fellow Massholes play
Bioshock and drink a treehouse brew
while wearing a pack seize land yes we
all kudos hitting all the buzzword cuts
is the way she said gears to a Dark
Souls protect this man at all lady I get
a building salute Yuri no tremendous
five Dom I gotta ask you if you got to
revisit real quick yes sir
you had some very strong choices last
time well people don't wait up
Super Mario RPG yeah Mass Effect 2 Zelda
franchise you had Halo 3 shots a cargo
about it agrees it costs lit right here
and then NBA Jam tournament but did any
of that change or is that is still
engraved in stone so ok so it has
changed a little bit oh and just a
little bit because I actually was trying
to recall from memory I feel like I need
to like keep it written down just till I
keep myself on us to keep myself
consistent so yeah first first most
favorite game of all time is Super Mario
RPG 7 legend of the seven stars for the
Super Nintendo I keep keep that thing
he's got a picture of in his wallet no
cap yeah the hole the cartridge is right
that's right exactly yeah so Mass Effect
2 is still up there mom NBA Jam
tournament Edition oh that's still there
so if you if you free smoke at any time
yeah yeah I know absolutely John
Stockton good from anywhere anywhere
shadow Dhabi David have Jordan in the
game with the licensing salute you could
have had a whole episode of the last
dance just on that Jordan
that's because Jordan wanted what was a
trouble in the Windy City and it was
like garbage
he had the fire basketball and a nice
basketball it was just probably doorman
that's like Shaq full levels continue so
yeah Mario RPG Mass Effect 2 NBA Jam
tournament edition yes so I have moved
halo down to the honorable mention like
six slot so and you know it's it you
know it depends on what kind of mood I'm
in like Halo 3 or Halo Reach honestly um
one has come in World of Warcraft
honestly is one of my favorite games of
all time I can't ignore it just on based
on the sheer amount of time that I've
spent playing that game and how invested
I am in the Lord of that game a Legend
of Zelda breath of the wilds holds down
the five spot let's go man let's go talk
about know why attack breadth of the
wall
talk about that NBA Jam in addition sir
yes yeah anytime you want that smoke
anytime you in this city how do you need
that smoke is right here I can see it I
see the opening menu right there shaka
laka is all five you know we got 295
people hit everyone hit that like let's
get those lights up tremendous fire okay
doc it to you and then yeah that was
that yeah Mario RPG Mass Effect 2 NBA
Jam World of Warcraft and Zelda breath
of the wild honorable mention Halo Reach
/ halo 3 right also just because you had
reminded me of it and with Mortal Kombat
11
I think Mortal Kombat 9 is like in yes
huh yeah and easy it's like it's up
there like just in terms of what they
did with the lore of that game and you
know what you know just the going back
to basics battle oh so good
they literally reinvented themselves a
and graphical fidelity and just
everything man tremendous tremendous
tremendous now gotta bring it back to
Bob real quick and consoles them didn't
do this for you last time oh dami chair
so we going we're not getting back to
Bob I need favorite console of all time
any generation hmm I mean that's this is
favorite of all time I mean the n64 is
an easy grab just because it was the
first it arguably it had some of the
best games that I've ever played mmm
granted the only one I listed here was
Majora's Mask Game Boy Advance was like
incredible - yeah like like this is my
child okay the question the question is
that did you play the Pokemon games what
was your first Pokemon game was a silver
yellow I always play blue and red I
never played yellow cabal what you gotta
pick one of them kids one of your kids
gotta be the favorite
it's either n64 Xbox 360 no no no no no
Rob what is wrong with you combination
two why why I mean numbers-wise isn't it
still the highest selling console of all
time right did you only buy one of the
hold of two hundred million
[Laughter]
it had every single game you wanted to
play out you know outside of the Xbox
exclusive but like the only Xbox
exclusives at that time or Gears weren't
halo yes what 2.0 solve you got a super
chair yeah I got Pete Carlyle gaming
with the $5 super chat it's time to get
hyped for the June 4th PS 5 or real
let's hope they knock it out the park I
can't play play the book of played
yourself
you got a logo calm down bro go get to
the topics coming but we gotta finish
this last talk
so PlayStation 2 PlayStation oh yeah
dark I think I asked you this 108 we was
doing consoles at that time yeah I never
asked you this I know you you're very
very gamer so I'm very curious gun to
your head
Oh what is your favorite muscle of all
time
Nintendo's with all confidence
[Applause]
curiosity what was your top
mummy
listen given the boss yeah so and it's
not just about it's not just about like
my whole top five doesn't have to be
switch games to have that be my favorite
so it's my favorite I felt like if it
was your favorite called so you have at
least two switch games in there or God
in them in the podcast last week I've
found more like a higher appreciation
for my switch because I don't have to be
sitting somewhere I could be anywhere at
any given time for it I can lie down in
bed I could go I go sit by a pool oh
yeah go can't do that anything else
bring it down in terms of your xbox if
you just app and then you know just open
up your phone you just go do it let them
know what my I'm so like my xbox 360
probably in terms of like having played
the most like having made the most
friends like heaven you know the most
like expiry
on a console it's probably the xbox360
just in terms of like overall usage and
impact and you know like the the
classics that it that have been
expanding a sway bar dad stay on your
square platform staying back why you
don't have to stand on anything oh my
bars let them know like my and I've
tweeted this probably a thousand
different times I feel like this is like
a like a drunk text that I'll send to
anybody like their Nintendo switch to
like everybody and nobody like the the
Nintendo switch is my favorite console
that I have ever purchased with my own
money and it's like I mean like you know
when you get older and you gotta like
you know I know that we don't have a lot
of people your age in this podcast I had
to tell Bob to open up a bank account
instead of the old Italian man in our
life that told us how to taught us how
to manage our money the small faces on
the outside yes in the middle there you
go that's right there you go so yeah so
basically the reason and the reason
being I had this revelation so there I
was on a beautiful island of Santorini
and I was thinking to myself what could
make this view better mmm and it was
just like man I would love to just play
play some video games right now but I'm
not at home hey what can I possibly be
doing what could you do that maybe but
how could I experience one of the one of
the greatest adventure games to your ex
cloud app continued internet outlet
continued back to this with me to be on
tethered I need to be uncovered so went
into my physical got a cap and go
I'm done with this continue I need to be
I need to be untethered so I went into
my suitcase I got a Nintendo switch I
put my feet up on this like nice little
infinity pool that we had going is the
Sun setting beautiful island okay it's
okay
not yet did the bottle verse off but
anyway yeah no so the Nintendo switch in
terms of just like the the amount that
they've done with this library what
they're doing with third-party
developers to make sure that every type
of gamer can be represented and have a
great time comment with the new
iterations of the of the classics that
we appreciate and just like the the
level of connectivity
I mean Nintendo is still about 10 years
behind the times everybody have to say
you know but they didn't intend to look
like Manny being Manny's why we always
have to say when it comes to Nintendo
both of them though I'm really sick and
tired that we're making this lane just
for them you know but what's the
Nintendo they're doing good know like
notes of the Danny are not the best
they are just actually mediocre at best
which by all means for me as far as I'm
concerned it doesn't even have internet
cables you know the Xbox
I think so that Playstation the switches
compete with the series X the PS far
they compete with the Xbox one and ps4
anyway anyway switch in turn just in
terms of versatility the different
experiences that you can get and with
and as far as the offline experiences go
it's my favorite console that it's my it
is definitely my favorite console god
yeah absolutely
but unlike aside from having it be yeah
my favorite console we were actually
talking about those in the podcast
earlier in the week and we were saying
that like like I hate to even be like as
I'm getting older because I'm not that
old gonna be turning 30 this year but
like where we're making milestones you
know we're looking for a house you know
we're trying to we're trying to do stuff
like you know in our lives and and I
find less and less time to actually like
sit down and like have time to really
likes it like really immerse myself and
be like you know dedicate have dedicated
gaming time you know and all that other
stuff straight on through because he
knows where this is going because I'm
trying to open his mind up X cloud app
to your phone so you can just lead that
other thing that you got going over that
little 40p stuff because you know my
phone is really 4k it really get busy
when when you see what your funky really
how I guess
because right now you talk about
untethered and you talking about loose
this you--you'll robot you got your
robot in your hand right
what feel good for you
X cloud is here you have the power of X
which has been so we got familiar with
the flowers over chat
let's not dilute a good topic with sales
minecraft has sold over 200 million
units attack keep it fair and we are got
it let me do a couple of them now yeah I
don't know where you okay daddy was
$2.00 chat I could have a beer with
these two subscribe anybody anybody in
our town that has not subscribed to
Willy gold we've got a $2.00 super chair
from Smitty Smith
sorry bro it's only one book and it's a
book X so we got a $2.00 super trap from
my stitch this is due on so this do this
is on some amazing drama which toki then
we got uh we got $100 $99.99 from Willy
Hood don't make income for the knees the
world you are on to something cause all
God I knew I'm definitely with total
beside the bus we got a fighters from
Chapman filling ego at the end of the
day to each their own rep your preferred
consul peacefully like he's doing
respect no no continue this is that's
all you wanted of it and we have Pete
Carlisle with the flattops Cooper chat
King stop fraud and you know damn well
that's treason race full of firearm to
it we got a chip we got a $2.00 super
chat from sis you need a phone plan to
play to talk online and all the slips
your babysit we gotta move over back as
we're talking argue and go it all Davis
we got to get to this pole man look last
week's poll results are in people who
spoke in to the MPD tracking Final
Fantasy 7 remake as the best-selling a
game of April and third best selling
game of 2020 which of these games do you
think ends up being the best-selling
game of 2020 so coming in at first place
the winner cyberpunk 2077 for sale Wow
covered at second sadly dog is 90% was
Animal Crossing at third place sadly
bomb was last of us - in last place
you're only 8% of the vote was I don't
care Final Fantasy 6 is still ago
disgusting
shout out to all the Lord participated
in last week's poll Lord King you are
victorious here so let's give it back to
you what do you think about this to fans
who agree with you they're sitting there
riding with cyberpunk
and the world has spoken you see the sad
part about it is you have to be smacked
around on abdomen and I'm glad they just
smack and started light and heavy by the
end of the year where was the card in
all of this hot ACOG not get you know
what I get it with the people with a
vote it's all gonna do exactly what they
did
I'm gonna be blind to the situation I
don't see anything I'm blowing almost
random zooming cod doesn't exist
this this is what I have to deal with it
has to be shown to be believers keep
beating them until they understand we
are legion I'm gonna love taking the
knees man and I'm with the shea butter
on the back you know on from Lord Jim
man the statement the shot heard round
the world
Thursday June 4th 1 p.m. Pacific Pacific
4 p.m. Eastern they have come out and
said they are going to share some new
things about the PlayStation 5 he said
he's excited to see what's going on he
said these games come to rep here coming
to PS firearms at the best in the
industry from innovative studios that
span the globe studios both larger and
smaller and those Nord will be
established so it's gonna be a digital
showcase will run for about an hour and
hit hit the news waves and broke the
internet so we got to get this thing
started so before we actually get these
stars I get my bars offer a quick solve
oh yeah so you know you don't have the
official you know announcement is here
and you know this is not a bed in each
segment
oh what's that date okay I put on my
public apology this is the first time
I'm really happy to be wrong so now what
it was is it was a larger show that
there was gonna push it back as they
want to have everything in it they
wanted to have the show the show was
gonna now what they're gonna do is the
shortest show and it's gonna stay on a
date I guess they wanted to keep that
date because there are other things in
place for that day so that's a good
thing
then it acts
coming so you know okay okay it just
doesn't help my emotional distress I'll
be I was I was scarred being sovereign
we were told that you know not this
year's die drop in oh wait wait wait
wait you think just because you're gonna
see some games you think the system
coming guys can't be using that name
definitely knows how to play them boss
I'm telling you this is not a luminous
and you're in the healing process my
brother you of the camera recording I'm
because we need to record him right now
because the last dude he was camping for
it was a question I talked about 80 and
man
my destiny order to PC stop anyways
let's stay focused let's say folk switch
the news has come out obviously we know
the whole deal so I want to bring it to
the realm when we get to a round table
let's start with our wicked gaming
brothers you know I'm saying like what
are you guys feeling about this news
what are you're expecting you know I'm
saying stop what uncle DOM and what are
you feeling about the June 4th date and
what could be show ID I'm not exactly
sure I you know I feel like I can't get
too excited just because the the first
couple of reveals if you want to call
them those for this console generation
haven't exactly been off to the
smoothest start you know aside from the
Xbox series X news just this previous
week which we'll get to there hasn't
really been much to get that excited
about and like the third party stuff
cool like the non gameplay stuff school
I think state the state of play thing
again which we'll get to you know put
things back into like things are
starting to get like real lines so
hopefully we can get a really exciting
reveal from from PS 5 this you know what
is it this coming week and you know then
to follow hopefully you know we'll see
Phil Spencer blow everything out of the
water when we get that a loan infinite
reveal couple weeks later you know
infinite isn't even being made the game
doesn't exist just waiting for you I
just want to decide the kill box put
your knees on this so I would like your
one good me ship demeanor we are we
saying Bob that just sidebar that halo
oh wow laughs that kid we're going to
see will see the first gameplay trailer
of Halo with it quote-unquote gameplay
trailer because I'm talking about
or software Oh whatever quote gameplay
trailer halo infinite we'll see that
maybe in 2022 and then with an expected
day before you let's get those knees so
Bala you lose all of these you have no
knees like Bob if he's going to agree to
these terms or better be on camera halo
infinite release heads-up before okay
yeah before place oh okay I'll be right
over the boss and I do matter of fact I
just come pick my knees up but oh about
to lose every let's get so again wit
with this news you know what what are
you feeling Bob like in reference to
this whole thing man the state of play
you know jewel fall for whatever ps5
game reveal first party third party
where we got man
I mean my expectations are so hampered
after the Xbox series X game when he
showed you that logo in that call also
need to do is show I'm gonna say six and
a half minutes of actual in-game
gameplay they won they already had a
better available what happens if they
only show like horizon they show a
little game player that they show like
Ratchet and Clank and the rest of
third-party gameplay hmm I mean that's
fine what do we think we saw what was
the only first party Xbox game that they
showed off
then if they do show or Poli showcase
yeah sure I mean if you went into that
showcase man that is unfair you three
four Soviet there but and you said this
is Microsoft's game they gonna show
Microsoft and they told you right the
day before the week before the mum
before a yoke third party showcase this
is you know the leftover from no but
you're missing a word there this is a
third party gameplay anything look at it
right now I want the same amount of
energy that you have all stored up be
hard booming out on Thursday because I'm
gonna call you right after this you on
scene make sure you respond to read that
you're all Gavin masses and your
eyeballs was watering and and magic mark
mark Cerny came out with the I want ears
in a box y'all was looking I was like
man this is not what we paid for or that
other time when y'all pulled up think
it's something other than gym dance move
sent and PlayStation five logo like been
away I mean I'm gonna tell you right now
you're not back in a thousand Oh would
be different but I want you to stand on
that squid I really do because next week
if they don't show what they supposed to
and you're trouble what let me get it
back about what what would you like to
be show about like what what would
excite you all I want is a new Ratchet
and Clank game or or let's see or a
revival of a long-lost franchise like
Sly Cooper Jack and Dexter they have so
many great IPs that they just don't
utilize anyone that's like what is give
me like a infamous three I'll be tough
that's what's up Lord addict man jewel
forth it is here I know it was highly
contested for a little bit for you but
it is here like what are you feeling
what do you think they're gonna show me
addicts in the bushes oh no I don't know
you're talking
[Laughter]
I thought you talked to the king for
some reason III think Sony about to come
out there and uh release the floodgates
yeah I think I think Sony don't play the
outside now they got time they're told
they were scared it pulled up as we
pulled up now okay they pulled something
because they won't pull it up for a
while but they pull it up now eventually
you go into pulling up by me just
because you last in the race so mean you
ain't never gonna finish but you did say
like you you expect a strong showing you
expect something pretty breeds I do I
expect a strong showing uh I expect like
25-30 percent of it to be first party
and the rest to be third party I expect
we'll actually see gameplay from von
hallor there okay uh I expect that but
for some reason on the PlayStation
Magazine fine how this top title in it
okay you know I have to see how that
goes
it's gonna be interesting I'm kind of
curious how like Demon Souls looks
because I'm pretty sure that's gonna be
there I'm pretty sure retching clinks
gonna be there I don't think spider-man
is gonna be there a lot of people think
spider-man's going to be there let's be
realistic here there's a lot of people
on Twitter that thing so you're gonna
come out there they go announce God of
War you shake on announcer rising 0.2
they're gonna announce they're gonna
announce blood board two and they're
gonna announce ratchet clink they're
gonna announce the like everything it's
like that's not what's gonna happen I
think you know they're good they're
gonna show what's gonna come out for the
console within like six months to a year
they're gonna show what's gonna come out
on launch they're gonna show like look
Demon Souls that's on launch I do think
that's what's that game called I think
ratchet and clanks on launch and I think
they're going to build up and they're
gonna end it with Verizon but for some
reason I think they're gonna have a
third party exclusive that we can expend
I'll be pretty big let me get you super
Chancellor quickly Mr Bond I think Eric
J is well I see my brother from rapping
game in perspective to lots of chats
ank's ILP fam for the last during his
craziness you already know trying to
keep the positivity and keeping some fun
JT gamer two hours of a chat let's get
this
out the way is Sony buying Sega that is
a big no-no big rumor going on you play
very coy yo you I would love to play
poker with you know what's really
happening but I kinda have a bob make
sure those knees is ship next day
[Laughter]
JB gear with the file a suit yet how
high will the production value be for
the Sony tuned for net and will
Microsoft learn and adapt making the
July showcase so much better I do think
that there's gonna be a lot of
production value into the Sony thing
this fourth of July event and the
question is I think that Microsoft will
adapt to it but do they have enough time
to realistically do anything drastic
right mm check goalposts moving live on
camera folks yeah JB gear with the two
dollars to attend who will have the best
third-party exclusives into any 20
Raymond Thornton mm heh why do you think
Sony cut the number of games down they
had a bunch of trailers line up yeah
they do it was a huge I wouldn't get to
my uh elemental feel with the $5 I don't
expect a strong showing I expect in
these EA games there may be two
exclusives first party games no launch
titles from first no launch titles from
first party no I think that Kentucky
launch house I think that it would
definitely good they're gonna I mean we
wouldn't even see an AK 3 they're like
they're what they're gonna have is they
don't have like that 3 punch out there
really decent game that's on launch like
the demon toes and they're gonna have
like two games that complement that game
like they're not gonna come out there
you know horizons on launch by doing
nothing like that I think within six
months after launch horizons gonna draw
like like deep down out the loop Lord
the insect migos just sending some green
love yo salute the brother he had the
other field dominance I got total feel
down on itself
cop t-shirt and put it up on Ohio
physical my brother's separate goes Xbox
expansion podcast we got to get him back
on man good that mean with that picture
so I can actually send that to Phil
[Laughter]
manual to two dollar super chat Sony
wants your eyes for the one our knack
three deep that's what you're gonna get
that's dynamic for three wait a minute
they're going to show games with no
console are they going to show SSD in
one hand in the continuous that is a
good question do you think this for Bill
is gonna have the console let's go right
to solve yeah what are you feeling do
you think they're gonna show the console
as well
I don't know cuz that did this this
morning they sort of tease like the
startup sound so it's like they're doing
that sort of stuff
and come on man the console has to be
ready to show why would you not show a
console I'm gonna say we see the console
I wanna see it alright games and then
and beyond that games that listen I
think I'm seeing little bits of the old
PlayStation madam I come out there it
definitively says we're launching this
year worldwide
that's one more goal then he comes out
and says then he comes out and says hold
on come down and says he's like yeah you
know the next-gen starts with
PlayStation 5 because we're showing you
things that can't be done anyplace else
that that's also me that's right back
Petie Sony
yes or no yes no let me say so real
quick I've see I've been seeing people
you know talk about the whole trucker
had think the truck ran things happening
you don't have to get 400 likes alright
but I will say this if you get 300 locks
in the next three shows all wear the
overalls - oh my god so we got that and
then um now solve I wanted to bring it
to you it's something we haven't talked
to it update I'll give it to King is
this whole thing about generations right
well we're hearing from them
but we're here for them is you know they
feel their philosophy which is about it
but different from Microsoft which is
they want to utilize the tech in the PS
5 they don't necessarily want to be
quote unquote held back by you know
pageantry and they want to move people
forward immediately so let's get in that
like what do you think about them being
very aggressive and standing on s square
well that's the square they've always
stood on and for me it's it's I'll be
honest is BS you know it's because it
really is like and we again with it
there's been Twitter back
no III I look at the other side of the
argument it's a philosophy to me listen
when you're talking about if you're
going from if you're saying this game
cannot be done on the playstation to
this ps1 game can't be done placing yeah
of course it's a monumental leap right
tell me something that can't on can't be
done on a ps4 from to the PS 5 that's
marketing speak that's you purposely
pushing down dan surprise it is
marketing they said we believe that when
you go to all the trouble of creating a
next-gen console that it should include
features and benefits from the previous
generation does not clue include he said
it in that and our view people should
make games that should make utilize
those features he's right but if you
look at what what are the features right
is the Elif adela T right but the SSD is
a bespoke thing that is that is to be a
console right right it's something that
removed from that whatever games you can
run whatever games you have a PS 5 can
run on the ps4 right they are they gonna
look as good no are they gonna run as
well
no but it's you tell me that there's no
way there's no way in hell these games
can run on here you're just trying to
sell me a new card I think Gina is right
we talking also about the PS 5 to ps4
because we know the series X you
technically can play Halo infinite yeah
the Xbox one X so right in this case one
way concern right we know you played a
witch on a switch sovereign is saying is
the absolute truth you know if in your
hardware that you don't have a software
solution right you understand Microsoft
has done it in a software form it's not
holding back nothing on the system it's
scalable so what what sovereign is
explaining it to you this did this
absolutely yes because they don't have a
software solution for a hardware problem
nestled listen we hopefully will be able
to expand on this on future podcasts and
stuff like that but I will say this
building scalability into software
forever that is the nature of software
especially if you're trying to build saw
we're for multiple platforms that's just
what it is like it's always been that
way so - you're creating the wall garden
right by saying no this can only work
here no you're forcing it to only work
there that's cool but that's that's more
narrative thing now than anything else
never to be creating the wrong way oh we
on the are we on the backwards
compatibility we kind of we kind of just
transition over because less often it
when you're going from one gen to the
next you tell me that's impossible
on the previous gen that's just you're
just trying to sell me new console and I
get it I get it but it it's somewhat
disingenuous to say that okay okay what
do you feel it will be show you don't
say I do believe they you know the
rumors about Ratchet and Clank being in
production for a long time so I think
ratchet Clank I do believe we do finally
see blue points game and all signs point
to Demon Souls beyond that we will get
teasers I think would whichever big
first party game is closest to being
released we'll get a tease of which is
probably horizon and then the third
party stuff is gonna be interesting it's
gonna be interesting to see how these
how these deals move forward you know
from this generation these third party
deals and because I think is still
important yeah well a lot of people hold
on hold on slow mo or softly he said
this off have this save energy when the
medium dev said they put in the game on
Xbox Live execs because it couldn't be
done or current-gen but why can't it be
done on current gen right it's the SSD
thing right so remove that remove the
bespoke part of the hardware that
doesn't look like a PC right or raisin
not exactly like a PC and you tell me
that game cannot run on on you're
creating the wall garden this is
specifically what I'm saying you're
creating the whole garden in order to
sell me a product I did it I understand
but it's BS when you tell me it can't do
it and there's a difference between
control and like a third party indie
developer saying they can't do something
because it may be like resource or
something and Sony telling you can't be
done really run as well would it would
it be is optimum no it won't be but
don't tell me it cannot happen
mmm yeah I think if you want my honest
opinion I
we'll talk about that later but in terms
of like the market he doesn't stuff I
think a lot of people don't realize how
strong marketing does are I'm willing to
bet you like statistic wise if we had
those numbers the the third-party
marketing does so one more concerts than
exclusives I've ever have I mean but it
in fairness do you not think there's
anything from a design standpoint that
can't run you know I'm saying that that
basically is just not really strictly
marketing is strictly just trying to
talk about the bestowed feature like
obviously if you use that SSD to its
full capacity you're able loading
open-world yeah we still you we've yet
to see it well all we've seen is a dis
gen game loading super quickly in a way
that honestly isn't it isn't even
playable like it's our new so fast it's
not even playable right so I'm true I'm
trying not to talk about the viable
because the thing is to me it just again
I don't begrudge them the need to sell
them it's sell their conscience I don't
begrudge the fact that they do it a
certain way their their philosophy is
different to my you guys though we did
did you guys see how they took the that
phrasing off of their website let's get
kicking real quick all pics a bit um
yeah so he got lies they built the best
backward-compatible system ever in
PlayStation 3 they built the PlayStation
5 with the ps4 of mine cerny
even said if on his Tech Talk now they
sell in smokin BX okay alright
but I'll be W ya know I was gonna say I
mean sovereign got it but it was like
the the philosophy is different so it's
it's like I mean we're gonna get and
we'll get to this that's probably like a
great segue but like the PS 5 has a lot
of focus on like this is this is a these
are benchmarks that the previous
consoles can't hit like this is you have
to buy this new hardware and like you
know the the this is like this this is
an impossible feat um yes full you know
right hey this isn't possible
achievement that you can't get all these
triangles
right sorry
but meanwhile like you know I'm reading
all this stuff about the series X
backwards compatibility and it rec quote
is that all titles will run at the peak
performance that they weren't originally
designed for would you put a you know I
mean they get they it's like the smart
delivery stuff where it's like it
doesn't matter what console you bought
it for but like if your point like will
make sure that you're optimized up to
get it and it's like it seems odd to me
where like PS 5 or so let's let's just
say that like PlayStation is so focused
on these first party titles that are
impossible to play on previous consoles
but for like Xbox where they don't have
as much console selling titles they're
saying that like you can play it on any
of our consoles so I feel like it's
almost backwards ok you know if I don't
know maybe I'm getting my wires crossed
here but like it just seems like an odd
mix up of priorities where like you have
these beautiful first party titles like
shouldn't you want maximum like look
shouldn't you like want maximum people
to be able to able to produce that as
far as for sitting over to the next
generation you talk about from a
software sales and yes your base
standpoint right because we don't know
that the the older job I see what you go
with I'm sorry I got I miss Vogel scream
shout the volca screen with the 2000
which at he said attic challenge
accepted you ready I know what he
thought he's talking about the the
overall thing I'll make another one man
if I if I see how if I see consistent
300 likes I will stream on the IOP
account I'll string on war 2018 I have
to see a thousand likes for me to say
that let's get kick back kick it wait
patiently yeah I'm gonna be able to for
our super chat imagine buying a PC that
could only play ten games but couldn't
play your games from three years ago
I do think it's gonna be an issue for
them if it
it's not done right maybe not for the
long run but for a while oh man picture
big enshou files of a check machine
learning in a Rai are big finesse again
we're sorting like I wanna are we gonna
just are we just gonna get prettier
pictures at 30 frames per second we're
better loaded go PS Wow Wow
you might be on to something awful well
you know listen I want y'all to temper
expectations of going forward you know
listen we already been bamboozled by a
couple of things that happen so far and
so it's saying you gotta continue
continue because it's been you have to
read the words right and you know Jim
dance move Ryan he's not dance out there
for you gonna do the shucking job and
he's gonna do all that stuff he's a dog
and pony show oh my god and this stuff
has to get sold to you alright so um in
magic marks I mean this is what I expect
for y'all to see what do you expect
right I expect that demon souls game
okay the same way that we saw a deep
down and never got it um I expect I
expect you to see that game and you're
probably gonna get it three years later
mm-hmm um I expect you to see nag three
launch title game three baby I expect
the world to open up I mean you mean I
want nak three but neck 1 & 2 was on the
system you know this is marks did this
is the father of the PlayStation 4 and
the PlayStation 5 mm-hmm he told you to
mail him here your ears so if you're not
listening because you think I know is
but if you're not listening is because
he's gonna make sure that he gets what
he wants and he should because he's
worked very hard to achieve what he what
he has gotten right so neck three is
gonna be shown okay all right then
you're gonna have a whole bunch of third
party titles that's gonna be playable on
both consoles so I want that same energy
I want you guys to be so happy and that
you're going to see third party stuff
that's gonna play better on his series X
all right and everyone there's for sure
one third party game
that's quote-unquote rumored but almost
confirmed at this point that's going to
be Sony exclusive that's Silent Hill
next-generation Simon here go download
and you might not have to work until
2021 and get a PlayStation 5 because
they're gonna release all over the world
beyond release 2 in each state you know
what listen
that means they did it though right okay
um you're not getting it 6:50 you not
buying it stop it now okay all right so
um and there's a lot of people to this
this they can't I listen to the
narrative well you guys mm-hmm y'all
expect a lot from what they was giving
you was so little so you think at some
point in time when it was making you pay
per Mille they gonna give you a buffet
are you out of your mind how many times
do they have to smack you for you to
understand this if they would've went
with the original because it was going
to do a blast out mm-hmm right and I
think somebody said I honestly think
something happened that they have to
they had this shorten it up and I think
concentration well I think addict is
right that they probably had a bunch of
trailers or something like that and
after they saw the negative feedback of
the Microsoft third-party showcase mmm
they was like you know what let's just
focus on what we have for gameplay let's
put that out there so we can keep this
narrative because they need any positive
press that they can get right from the
to negative showings that they did show
the logo gate and then mark see me with
the edge
all that stuff is definitely negative
now you will have playstation dude
spinning as a positive and I understand
if this is your console of choice and
you've purchased all this stuff there
you want this stuff to go forward I
understand I feel you you you want to
hear about it that's good that is you
supposed to champion your system that's
a mess great class but temper
expectations because if you don't I will
definitely be smashing nothing alright
so if you come out here saying stuff for
a year they're gonna have this one
they're gonna have that and I expect to
see banjo-kazooie 5 and listen listen
listen
stop alright um you might get a logo you
might get a listen you you might get you
might get opening they've like zero
horizons on the short plane a lotion and
they show it out and they show all the
little kinds of little robots out on the
floor and they pan away you don't see
the game for another five years so we go
get a JPEG no digging up that's not be
actual gameplay
listen temper expectations you you have
last of us there and they might touch on
the fact that those games they're
certified after July right it's all
those are the games that you can really
look forward to their code word for word
all right okay you're gonna get probably
two or three games one first part again
which I know is gonna be net all right
and and you're gonna get you know to
other games to go with that and then
you're gonna get third party showing
nothing mind-blowing nothing no
exclusive that will get the masses and I
guarantee use the PlayStation loyalists
if this is gonna be the narrative but
that nak dough and then they gonna say
but next week we go get last of us there
week ago sister Shima
there we go flying into that neck and
then and then in July to go show us
something everything is but next
mmm-hmm everything is but next time mmm
I mean has it has it Microsoft of doing
that for like to know what actually my
love hasn't been doing that actually
what Microsoft don't showed you was a
console straight it was no but next time
mmm-hmm it was yo but uh did you found
you brick I mean they cat they kind of
literally just did that with the third
party stuff here's some third parties to
but next time listen they said this is
the stuff that we have overflow right
now while you're sitting here waiting
mmm-hmm snack on this right who's got
upset with the snacks that they got
right no I get that but but let's sell
what a logo feel what you say but at the
end of the day it's like the equivalent
of what you you order you know you're
good
hey barbecue wings we ordered some
barbecue wings but we didn't get
barbecue we like chicken nuggets like
they told you on the box it was no
barbecue wings coming I'm sorry bro
it wasn't a good nuggets and be quiet
okay in fairness the Dera t'v was they
were scared the narrative was they had
nothing to show the narrative was that
the game I'm gonna tell you this right
now they got some pretty sure I said I
got said the petit coming out and they
are notorious for taking Microsoft's
missteps a phony phone me Eddie Sony I'm
telling you right now when parity you
they're gonna show somebody playing a
game and with the controller this is
gonna be our first reveal what you want
it wait for you to sit there with your
faces say damn in here I'm sorry okay so
you may see you you're still standing on
your square this is not the same story
that we build this is something this is
somebody different and we better tap the
exit stage because gonna take it is the
old regime you're gonna slice
Tony see the other Sony would throw the
rock and punch in the mouth right this
Sonia's throw to rock and hide his hands
no those people when people look around
it throw the rock this Sony will say
something and then go back to the
homepage and erase what he just you know
what he gonna possible deniability
give them a screen shot are you in flag
the PlayStation 5 page that removed the
back of that stuff from this one we've
aimed at the same PlayStation 5 phase
that was like the fastest most powerful
joint to be fair to be fair it's also
the same people erasing stuff from a
website and I say none to what I see and
I'm gonna tell you a lot of times they
beat it then it's not mark Sony is back
there with that Magic Mike anyways why
cracks on wax off we shot the Bradley
get this to a subject fight the power in
heavy rotation I feel brother Tom who
was do we miss did we get we got a $2.00
super chair from a ghost we get look to
luck to my gaming families stay safe
we got a fight on super chat from for
King I'm not reading that King you're
demanded to read that yeah hold on hold
on where does that $5.00 won my cold
wrap after June the 4th you got a real
breath okay Oh wrap okay after June the
4th which King said was never gonna
happen King is going to resume when we
name his knees Derrick Rose and what you
need to do you need to put out your Sony
flag and prep the team yo listen bring
that baby home
I mean I mean so if you apply their
profits like clean that baby on your
taxes you need to say that he is not
craving this child as his own
you sitting there reppin the baby but
you ain't claiming the baby what I want
you to do see because listen ain't
nobody on none of these shows will tell
you that King don't represent this X or
that's a fact-filled ominous Maximus
Spenser soon to be a real I still on a
square I'm not worried about you trying
to act like you fear media your fear and
you want to go while I'm PC but you got
a Xbox ultimate mmm you're playing xbox
over there oh but you know I'm fear um
you know but Sony anytime you only pop
out when Sony coming up jab gonna spread
j-dub I could respect portal rock
because those deep stand on a square we
know what they waiting like I wanna know
where your allegiance lies this PC
nonsan see I was not gonna do this to
you I was you made this happy baby so
the world is going to see right now I
want you to side just flip flop and all
let up don't expect a flip flopper I
mean just put your back straight say
will your chest
oh if we say he needs to old his so do
you see dr. Bob amen what he look you
right in your face
and see halos not coming from me coming
from I'd rather play everything on PC
anyway but if I if I have to throw my
hat into the ring
or a console discussion yeah I
PlayStation exclusives are too big to
pass up okay you gotta read the $2 super
chair from Smitty's pay he just said get
in there man with the polish 2zo tees
$10 there they better show SSD next-gen
game design
you know I met mods is wandering ones it
feels he that we're not getting a
council review now let's get we out with
well so we missed Midway Midway yeah
million might ah everyone get hype for
choreographing play stick you're my head
over everybody was that who else we got
those we got and we have missing which
at braaap braap on the Maury show that
can't stand you have no knees my side is
with games whoo yes thought is not we
games that is your fallback go to nah
it's not doing that just actually claim
that baby that baby need a daddy doesn't
say King doing God's work damn breath
yeah they try to say you gotta get the
paternity test you gotta you gotta clear
that was alive oh my gos that baby got a
weak neck Maury we miss gaming Forte
this is good we go see jewel forth is
coming you know say look at any game I
just love it bad it tightens around this
would be the week yes we would be at a
three it's kind of sad man this week
like fry like Thursday would be the last
day I worked until we back from me3 me2
yeah we know I'm jealous that I didn't
take those days off look we had to miss
it a little war down at least they're
outside you know I'm saying we got to
see what they go into shout out to
slow-mo everybody laughing a [ __ ] I
could kick Saddam's it well oh yeah look
man this is fun this is fun I just want
to see what they do you know I'm saying
I want to see how Microsoft pivots to
whatever they do I want to see the champ
be the champ
yeah yeah I'm going to see Rob Lowe will
be drugged listen this what we gonna do
we gonna
learn a lot about languages and how they
present when they have cooking if they
had stuff on in tuck or you know to
Kim's point King may come out like yo
see it got saying like I told you that a
lot of questions are gonna be answered I
feel weird unless it got made a good
point and Bob as well like they just saw
the marker saw you it's their party King
don't come for me but they just saw the
stumble so to speak right gameplay like
you kind of know what not to do right
it's a song label not to show logo some
point again oh sorry that we don't I say
that we definitely notice is they always
capitalize on these moments they always
be you know say have a verse in tuck for
this so is that's why say we're gonna
learn a lot about what they showed us
you know keep in mind you know 300 plus
people watch it definitely thought like
but yes also the Lord will be Live
Strong we always get Kings live
reactions to and taking this hour to
call in live after what I want you to do
is I want you to pull up while the show
was on really bout that while the show
was on so because I want you to go back
to the last two reveals a lot a lot of
fun of these reveals this is gonna be
interesting
it's hype is excited we got to move on
Lord soft man what is going on with Xbox
and this tech and what's happening man
what series X cool so yeah Xbox last
week this past week detailed a little
bit more about backwards compatibility
right and and how they were approaching
it with the series X and just their
philosophy in general moving forward
singing louder like fantastic things for
me for somebody who really cares about
an entire ecosystem and and just like on
PC being able to move all my stuff
forward and play this stuff I appreciate
and care about the fact that they're
taking all this time to to really
research and make
series X and every subsequent console
after that compatible pretty much
everything that's come before
so um a lot of the exciting things they
talked about were the fact that a lot of
older games would be able to run at
their maximum supportive frames per
second and typically these games are
unlocked they might be able to even push
some or some older games to 120 frames
per second um what the the philosophy
architecture that they were talking
about in addition to that with the
craziest part about it me is the fact
that they've created a software HDR sort
of implementation where you can
implement add HDR to games they did
that's kind of fine um in a way that's
that reasonable facsimile to actual true
HDR which isn't which is crazy I mean
and again hats off to them for all the
work they've done from the three from
the Xbox one forward really something
that we did not expect to see on the
console side especially in terms of
software right if we were looking before
they did what they did with the one we
always felt that backwards compatibility
was some sort of hardware solution that
you had into the and they figured it out
on the software side and they've only
continue to grow it so that is fantastic
by all accounts right all the counts
this is a fantastic good present taste
but then they turn around for no reason
you have to say this Xbox series X will
launch with thousands of games flying so
I little I rolled my eyes I looked up
and I said why did you have to say that
and why did you once again have to put
yourself in it and in a situational I'm
to be scrutinized are they put on is
that true yes no no for the individual
that purchased that Xbox for the first
time you sure that has gotten a game
pass I agree that has somebody did love
thirty bucks you know you can say that
you show me the banners first show me
the bag disperse the conversation no
because you know
because you don't want the sweet talk I
just want to get to the mix I'm already
in so why do you have to listen ten
years ago you stand on a box and say
yeah these thousands of games but we do
the average told you we haven't shown
you halo yet we haven't shown you which
we know is coming when you go to see the
show from people that's getting beat up
like that clap bad this is something
this is an announcement you don't even
have to make right after you announce
the bangers you let information trickle
out be like oh wow they could do that no
that's for me tell me why I need to buy
your cut your brand-new what does I love
that combat it is not okay before you go
I just have
it's like keep working with a rock and
he throws it in front of himself and
trips on it all about you and put it in
your mouth we get the bottom of you you
are on this square with Sony's back
kapap right now we already know what
what at the time what you got was mm-hmm
Sony was talking about backup at mm-hmm
this is when the tweet goes out mm-hmm
this is when the information thousands
because your man can't say it mmm when
you can't say something back where was
the clap back to the thousand so this
was the nos Stillmatic for playable
PlayStation games right they walk the
hell of that much when thousands gonna
be come Thursday where is it gonna
matter them they're gonna be asked
solved this question you should be
worried about your knees when you you
said they wouldn't have it after they
already announced they were gonna have
it because that's how to put your neck
so because you know it suffer from
Alzheimer's right now everyone in this
panel could safely say this the King
will make some outlandish
let me get to the bottom of it so you
know your thing is okay
are you upset dad Microsoft I mean it
I'm honey are you said that Microsoft
made this you the comet in general oh my
are you mad that they made it as a
response to something I'll try to get to
the root of how I feel
this was a misstep I to me the messed up
because this is information that comes
after you show me the reasons why I have
to like I'm already in if I'm going back
oh so your thing is the sequence of a
fifth you would prefer them so you can
say don't show this yet show the game
first pretty much you're pretty much
like look like they keep saying it's
tough show me stuff and then say stuff
can you agree me on this okay they have
yet to show somebody who's not in
already a reason to buy that box yet
right correct
so you're touting this back compat stuff
you're preaching to the choir regular
I'm in I'm good right okay information
for later and then beyond that even if
they put without that press release and
they allow people to analyze it for
themselves and talk about it don't put
out a statement like it's gonna launch a
thousands of kids once again you put
yourself in a position to be scrutinized
for no reason because we haven't shown
me ask you they say this is what I think
King is going right and I want to be
clear now to Kings Point right he's
saying most like that it not look at it
as a direct clap back to okay this is
why you gotta buy the system but what
he's saying is we can we at least admit
that Sony messaging has been unclear
will complete whether games are going
forward or backward
there hasn't been we've got bits and
pieces but you know until recently we
didn't really get definitive statements
so I think where King is going and
saying well if he if you know this is
your strength right you know big shot to
build some of those guys you we they do
back compact they're telling you smart
delivery so he said well why not
showcase your strengths when your enemy
is being indecisive and not showing you
know strength on that particular issue
that do you least understand that maybe
from a market I can understand it but
the problem with that is
they had the opportunity to come out
first and they didn't come out guns
blazing they party revealing came out a
little timid right they gonna reveal we
talked about whether they will ready or
not whatever the case may be
right so mocking is it this is not
information that once again is good if
your why are you gonna continue to
preach to the choir
the ones that you know are gonna buy a
system yeah it's already it's your fault
on conclusion so come out swinging with
the stuff that's gonna name words with
those new words Jim Ryun shouldn't say
stuff like you can only play this on
PlayStation 5 and he and show nothing
yet with those same words you should not
ever forecast anything you just want the
[Applause]
Lila just said real quick the lightest
hypothetical because what has been shown
the critical wood has been shown yeah
they've been banging it up no but your
words you don't want them talking ahead
of time no nothing show me first you
know we'll talk about you talk about it
but you put it up on a pedestal like
it's the greatest thing ever and it's
like no no
I have Mike says sauce say he pulled up
all girl and say no kisses update de
braga breath oh yeah yeah well bribe
Howell Don King spend $500 to play okay
Brad
find out what super chat still said that
we all didn't get a chance to all yeah
or what wait went away troll Lords yo
listen Brett for real um like a joke a
lot but we've definitely spoke the link
facts he was there then we have next is
one away dragon with the father I was
super chat y'all gonna stop coming for
my black rubber oh oh they just keep
playing around we keep playing around
and you see I have Chris he's doing some
cleanse thing JT gamer look so he's
gonna show up with a 500 SSD in two and
$20 GPU CPU now who's rockin with that
give me my swallow $2 GPU CPU with the
$200 SS Drive hashtag make a complete
system you know we got to put you have
to put your on to something in that
realm NOP Oh fine on a super chat King
IMAX Xbox has series X optimized what
will Sony's buzzword be might work on
PlayStation y'all messy Bessy who else
we got a $2.00 super chat from Pratt
okay we got a $10 super charm from JD
gamer
forgive me sir okay you read that
because it's not about you we hardcore
gamers often forget that we are only yes
I've said this a million times 10 to 15
percent of the market and when little
Billy's mom goes to the store though
games day one is very impressive no it's
not because it's not it's not a message
that's put out there
by I would say it's not something that
you put out there as a storm claw you're
gonna put out what's new and hottest I I
don't really see that being a selling
point for somebody just coming into the
ecosystem
I don't unless you have somebody really
in the know who's gonna sit down and
break that down to you in a store and
more often not not everybody's gaming
Forte like not I mean this is this
potential that the GameStop employee
explains those thousands those thousands
of games and little Billy's mom is like
wait why would I spend $500 on this when
we have all those back at the house and
the house already
I just brought those two weeks ago why
do we need all that now look sell lows
and go get a Playstation and you can
pick this up that you do it you know you
don't need to rebuy those games with us
Mart delivery okay can we I'm confused
on people's like stance like are we
saying like basket
backwards-compatibility is not relevant
like what I'm saying is that when you
compare listen I don't like kid don't
let them at the conversation for you I'm
not for Sony I'm just what I want
Microsoft to stop stumbling over
themselves and I just yeah I personally
like in my opinion I don't think them
saying that they have a couple thousand
games ready at launch is like stumbling
over them said no come on it is very
it's it's it's word playing it's like
content this isn't new news this is the
first time they say it in hell they said
that a couple months ago when that whole
thing happened with Sony they said it
they or two if they have an entire press
release around it in the boutique was
they had it there too yeah but it's
different is different when you go you
make an entire press release about that
compact right and I can appreciate that
it was in direct response to so let it
be about but but you you say you want
them to be or you know diverse and more
aggressive and do little bit more the
Sony does but Saudi tumbles of a little
bit over the backwards-compatible and
Microsoft wanted to capitalize on that
and now you say that's not good either
most of the time Sony doesn't so already
Tony already shows you the big guns
first
showed you a question
what's a Sony's back compare strategy it
doesn't matter what it is I need to no
matter what it need to know because
Microsoft told you there's please tell
me he said they already said it's not as
nearly as robust as what Microsoft is
doing argument argument what what
Microsoft was saying when see this is
this is exactly why they put that out
they put this out for you this was for
you because I like you
they're very unclear with what the hell
Sony's doing but Microsoft said hey hey
hey hey timeout hmm if you unclear with
what they're doing let's make this very
clear but what we're doing when you pick
up games is it better compare
third-party review right I've been off
the chain right they had stumbled again
but right by if they hadn't this would
bring differently in my ears right it
definitely would but at this point I'm
like why even bother I talk about the
big stuff first
I just this information trickle down and
let people be impressed by it just by
looking at it themselves you don't have
to tout this as the greatest and latest
that's Nesta bothers me I just talked
about the reason why somebody new coming
into the ecosystem needs to buy this
console right I feel like this is mainly
one of those this is the value that you
want like III get you you're like I
would do that attempt like I know value
I know it already
right but but can we say this there is a
subsequent we're hardcore gamers all of
us on this panel right we we have the
loudest voices right now but can we say
that at least this would provide value
to a group of people that maybe more or
less and then like like a little billy
stuff and all that then it would be
viable for and your end and I'm gonna
take one thing that you specifically
said we have the loudest voice around
this right now right despite however
generations play out right the vast
majority of consoles purchased are not
by the hard core the hard core the first
first ones in light
so the thing about it is that the
narrative is set already right if we at
this point right before the council's
come out our voices all would drive the
narrative until and until the the non
hardcore take over now honestly think
that the hardcore is it like they make
the narrative and they never have it is
going hard right so my thing is that I
personally feel when they do this and
they haven't talked about the big stuff
of that yet it it weakens their mouth
like you had I feel like if they had
like it would be different if they had
no date you know a couple weeks ago we
had that horrible third party showing
like you know it's horrible how they
promoted it like the event itself wasn't
bad it's hard that marketed now we go a
couple weeks from now and you know they
you know it's just them going on it
going on Twitter and putting the
articles like look people have questions
about backwards-compatibility
this is the answer like the article the
fact that they came out and said series
X is going to launch with thousands of
good at the third party event it's not
like they didn't tell you when this
other events gonna happen they're like
in July that's when we ready oh for sure
I feel like if that news if that
information was not available I'd be
right there with you I'm like you
wouldn't even know when the next dates
coming up we know the power of a few
choice words and how they're said and
when they're said we saw it in 2013 we
started 2013 we're in that space again
right so we cannot talk we cannot say
that I'm just saying understand a few
choice words
mix mix with not so great presentations
can do a lot for narrative nothing I
agree with it I'm not saying I'm not
saying this thinking isn't outlandish
but I don't think I agree with it I'm
just saying this is what happens we've
seen it happen right right oh it's not
possible absolutely I have to listen I
get where you're going I think I
definitely kind of lean on the side at a
good gig on this but the dig is this
backward compatibility is a feature it's
one of their strengths all right and for
me if I'm marking right I want to
promote that right I want especially if
I feel my competitor is shaky there
that's just me now I see you a point
with timing obviously we just had the
third part of your ID you're upset I get
it I didn't I didn't like that they did
they said game play all over the screen
and we ain't gay game play all over the
screen
I get it I just feel that for me it's a
little unfair to now say because of this
now I'm fearful of I guess the stuff
that they're tell they also told me at
that reveal that halo infinte they're
gonna do what you call it a showcase
that they're gonna do another but
possibly what is it July August showcase
so game doesn't exist because they so
for me I still have a road map so to
speak now if they would've did the
stumble data did just back a pack and
then I wouldn't have known anything else
coming then I probably be more where
you're at and trust me I'm with you saw
like I know the importance I know how
much they have to nail this III get it
to me we're weird only weird reasonably
only part I do sign on you even order
pejorative looking at it is that they
have now put a lot of pressure on
themselves for the next event right they
have to knock it out the problem if they
stung with this the first part is not
hitting if they not showing gameplay
like it's spooky right it's really
spooky and that about that's the only
part I sense with you as far as the
desperation it is think about it right
if not if this is the last thing they
say before their rent in July right and
let's say it's only knocks it out of the
park on Thursday right there's a whole
month of narrative that you you have to
dip and dodge through for a month until
you until you come out with your stuff
right right right I think I think that's
the whole point I think they want enough
time to come by tour when they talk
obviously they're always going to be
compared to the other guy it's never
gonna not be the case right but I think
the point of them splitting the third
party in the first party is they don't
want to announce her stuff before Sony
and they don't want announces of to
close after Sony because that's all
that's my next question which was that
notoriously then no let's be real if III
was this week right Sunday would be that
Microsoft show right historically night
historically right Sony comes after with
the chance to clap back this is the
first time in this saga of
next-generation reveals that they
actually have a chance to crack back
after the clap back as I say so but my
thing is part of me is I see the
strategy like look don't show your hand
all the way and I know you dealer
everybody is like no guns blazing
gunplay the clap clap clap but it's time
to start the cars I got Neal sorry bill
gave yours that but at the end of the if
you shoot and you let off the clip and
these dudes go home oh yeah okay fire up
the you know say daddy's like oh man
[Applause]
this is how you trade first party like
don't be soft
that's all I'm saying that's a little
what the thing is but either way it's
not the same because before you the clap
back was a day later but it sounds
always we have to admit so what if the
house is it's after June 4th right
uh-huh
then they do something the next week you
know you know most of the what if what
these do is what if how about I give you
a scenario of what they have been doing
like to do what ifs right since since
you to master the new what is right
since you yeah to The Watcher with the
what if okay alright how about this what
if right after market saw me Sony does
they little show who won or fourth right
what if they just released gameplay
footage of halo the same day and I doing
it
that doesn't that doesn't sound like
Microsoft he's talking about
doesn't sound like Sony nothing to now
right right
ad existed I think the flood gates are
opening okay what if work with your boss
and I gotta get my uber chats so what's
gonna happen is if Kings preaching we're
gonna see halo gameplay we're gonna see
halo something and then at the end of it
it's gonna be revealed to be halo wars 3
because other wave was a visor how many
have a backlog that are happy their
games come with them and are gonna be
series X optimized okay yeah pixel bit G
was next okay please get that if I miss
pixel because I saw a minute okay this
would be G with the file all the super
chat HDR for backup at games comes from
a direct yeah feature their PlayStation
5 doesn't have do more than just HDR and
I don't think that's why they're holding
their noting it now I think yeah okay
what what is doing and I think Don
touched on this earlier right
it's optimizing those games to run at
peak capacity right so when you put in
whatever this I mean if you have a Vox
1x right now and you play an old game
most of the time if it says optimize for
the X it has performance modes it runs
it in the best resolution the game looks
better it's it's stunning to see so what
they're saying now is no matter what now
it doesn't even have to be optimized it
automatically the resident get off the
rip off the rip yeah that's right okay
and this is the clap back I thought this
our room will be able to respect no
boost know boost mode no down clocking
just works right okay yeah it seems like
my narrowed has been twisted here our
respect for me as timing I'm a marketing
dude but I do not there's certain times
you just need to shut up and let the
product speak for itself but Microsoft
has been notorious for like I said
carrying the rock thrown it in front of
them and tripping on the same damn rock
I don't understand I don't with the dude
with the bicycle putting the stick in
the bike I get it restored hey t -
awesome chat though xbox showed more
next gen exclusive games and then we got
now Midway monster filed some chat how
many have a backlog that are happy that
games come with them and are gonna be
serious exile but brother Nintendo you
don't see a happy job y'all seen heavy
Japanese a good girl
fine I'll assume chat artist my do man
my uncle knows nothing about console
wars he bought an Xbox just because of
game pass casuals no value when they see
it game pass equals value that's what's
up JD gamer - awesome shot it's about
strength versus weakness back compat is
a Microsoft strength and then I think we
all win Michael a KB somebody good ok oh
no that's a my $2.00 chat saw he's
plucking out SME Raiden blade 2 pounds
who says Sony bangers take a generation
back with cata backward compatibility so
nice kid then we got JD gamer final
super chat
what's a king oh do i 60 frames per
second with HDR 4k is big news so we
know remakes remasters can't be expected
back a path have a lot of these jams
running on poly you want to see one
graphics you want to see that the
running no you want to see the running
animations in kotor when you have to go
outside in the submarine suit what are
you going like this if you want to see
that in 120 frames per second
I love you but you're not what I would
call objective I get it all I'm gonna
say real quickly with all this two below
um I thought the feature I thought it
was really cool I liked the fact that
you know it's doing it off the rip you
know I'm saying I think that's pretty
impressive
HDR reconstruction with stuff that day
listen there's there's going to be a
group of gamers that do not care about
this I get it mmm right but again all I
say is don't think about just yourself
as a gamer selfishly think about others
who I think are the majority who may
look at this as value kind of what -
Nintendo Gerber saying like game pass
backward compatibility smart leave I
just think these are value propositions
and I think that is been their mantra
like if you come with us the ecosystem
goes with us and you get all this free
stuff free 99 and I think that resonates
with something that's just me now to
sauce point I ain't that upset because
they said if thousands but solvate like
it that thousands - he don't put
thousands on you on your screen we would
have liked if they were said like mark
some he said 35 games say nothing like
you ain't got no first party party games
you don't say kind of joint and I want
to get everybody get they balls with dog
did you get your joist office yeah yeah
and I didn't want to I want you guys
Rock you know I mean so I know that um I
know that Bob is going like full zero
dark thirty on the last of us I've had
the block stuff on Twitter yeah because
of people leaking the last of us yeah
and and I I do unfortunately have a hard
stop coming up like really really
quickly so I'm gonna I just definitely
what yeah I mean we can talk about this
and then I mean the D so I mean the Xbox
backwards-compatibility thing I think
it's really exciting I still have my old
xbox360 hard drive because I didn't want
to lose my Mass Effect saves or my and
this was actually before the cloud stuff
before like the cloud stuff even like
really came out so I didn't have a
chance to save that to the cloud I'm
gonna do that I'm gonna like probably
just go I'll get my brother's Xbox 360
and and save that stuff to the cloud but
I still had this old hard drive because
I didn't want to lose my hundred and
fifty hours in Skyrim I didn't want to
lose my combines in 300 hours and the
Mass Effect
you know franchise across
like nine playthroughs you know like I
didn't want to lose that stuff so when
they talk about gaming legacies and I
saw some people like poking fun at that
phrase yeah on Twitter but like and
that's just because Twitter just it's a
hellhole all the time it's like not fun
to be on and like you just can't they
can't be like any sort of like fun on
anything really but like the but like a
deck gaming legacy stuff matters and
like for the people that still keep
super Nintendos and the bookcases and
like that type of stuff being able to
preserve that and still play and have
access to those same saves is really
great and that's really impactful so
like that matters it's not gonna like
I'm not gonna buy an xbox Series X to
play for Xbox one games I could do that
on Xbox one but luckily Microsoft has
given us the option to do both with
smart delivery which is great so I'm
glad that this is a priority for them I
can see why it wouldn't be a priority
for other people and they're like this
is you know that's like you know uh I
like it you know what I'm what about
there what about the solves point as far
as the timing right cuz solve definitely
he's standing on a square today
ya know say like I like that day they
shouldn't be talking about this now and
they need to be getting to these game
like yes how do you how do you feel
about that I agree yeah no I agree with
solve I think that like they this is not
like I'm glad that they said it I don't
know that this is the order in which I
would have announced it and say like you
know you're just coming hot off the
heels of people like skewering you know
like skewering these presentations
saying that we didn't get enough
gameplay and they had to like clarify
what they meant by gameplay and now the
same but wait there's thousands of old
games that you can play and that's cool
don't get me wrong but that should come
after you show us the new stuff right
and it's like but wait there's more now
you can also play everything on Xbox one
everything that was bad what's
compatible for Xbox 360 right like all
that stuff would have been an awesome
bookend and it's like and then you know
what you do is you go and it's available
today you know throw that okay okay
don't and like that's when you really
like give us that foundation you need to
like that have that really core like
exciting uh like library preview mm-hmm
give us some halo infinite gameplay
which which allegedly may or may not
exist
you know I'm gonna go out the women say
it doesn't thank you fo and then you say
and you know what and like for the
people who who will really like been
with us like since day one like all of
our Xbox fans who have been you know
like amassing these crazy digital
libraries with all these hard drives now
um guess what you can access that at any
time with your Xbox Series X and you go
all the way back and like that type of
stuff is that's that's how you make that
statement really impactful and that's
how you make it like a bulletproof look
like exclamation point but what you're
saying okay no fair enough King imma let
you get you get you to join off I'll see
you frustrated frustrated at all no
listen I really beat a dead horse um
it is what it is if you know you didn't
appreciate the fact that they gave you a
clear outline and how back a pat works
on what's going on and like you said
you're all in but it wasn't whew right
like a lot of people having a problem
with them actually showing something on
you know the the third-party reveals
right that's on you um and like a lot of
people not having a problem with showing
a logo yeah that's on you there are a
lot of people have not having a problem
with them showing you a fake GDC thing
that's on you listen however you want to
consume your information that's
completely on the individuals and I
understand that not everything is going
to resonate with everybody right but we
have to walk away from the narrative of
people making a messed up when they're
giving you information right now not
everybody is into show me the money
right other dudes want to understand why
right you know and a lot of times
leading up to the how is the why then
here's how and let's show so they told
you they're gonna have some shows in
June stick around on this you already
know July is coming stick around to your
point this is literally the first time
they're in the driver's seat right
tony is replying to whatever they have
done okay
and now they get a chance to reply to
that okay down oh yeah I got my wicked
boys and I got them I know I did a hard
stop so if you guys got a row let's get
you with the right outro out of here is
the same thing for you right you two
right you guys got things you got to do
yeah I just want to throw in one thing
if he's do plants compatibility I
understand both sides I think the it's
an accessibility thing because you're
allowing for so many games to be
essentially cross generation at that
point right it's a it's consumer
friendly you know and I in my opinion
probably the biggest thing that a lot of
people overlook is the games
preservation yes like we all we all that
we all go back we all go back
generations to like I said the first
console and controller I ever held was
an SNES mm I still have one I still have
the games that I had for it and like
there needs to be more systems in place
for that to be preserved and if this is
you know assisting in that 100% I'm
fluent supporting it yeah but um yeah
timing-wise I mean get some better
marketing managers you know I don't know
what to tell you you don't want to
follow up such a like faceplant of a
third party quote-unquote gameplay
reveal I don't know just last question
in fear did was this a showcase of it
was did they did they put they blare the
trumpets the Horde to name for your
backup reveal like some emails out this
meeting could have been an email well
let's get somebody here owes me a shout
out to our brothers wicked good gaming
still rocking with us we're always a
pleasure even though that in the flesh
in the spirit during this tough time you
guys are our brethren
ultimate respect we love what you guys
are doing for the culture and do
difficult times like this man it's
always good to just talk game and have
fun positivity unity in the game
so I start with my brother uncle Dom
wicked if my people find you what you
got going on sir yes so you can find not
another gaming podcast anywhere that you
find fine
artisanal podcast you can find us on
Spotify Apple podcast Google Play Music
stitcher tuning radio overcast radio
calm I Heart Radio all that not another
gaming podcast go check us out and also
twitch.tv slash wicked good gaming also
here on youtube youtube wicked good
gaming twitter is wicked good games and
every other social is wicked good gaming
so we just started doing voicemails that
we leave that we read live on the show
we listen to and react to live on the
show so as long as you don't get us TOS
you know we'll listen to and react live
on the show that's the wgg internet dad
hotline so yeah we got you so you can
give us a call but um
much appreciated guys thank you so much
and my personal twitter is at Uncle
Tommy you know I go by poppadom uncle
Dom you know whatever you know whatever
but um yeah I know everything kind of
sucks right now but like like I said on
Twitter like your Sundays don't have to
your Thursday's don't have to you know
we're here for you and you know we just
want to express our utmost love and
support you know to everybody in the
realm and out there in the world right
now and beyond
you know we this show has shown us that
you uh you know it goes without saying
that everybody is not afraid to speak
and not your mind and stand up for what
you believe in and there's a lot of
people out there in the world that are
doing that right now as we speak so we
appreciate you and we're showing you
nothing but love and support so let's
all say about that always loves always a
pleasure let's get let's get Bob get his
balls off big slander on Halo Infinite
today we go let that slide Tom covered
most of it we're also selling shirts we
discussed this on roundtable with the
stream team camera bird I can never
remember the actual fact the Boston
foundation kovat 19 PPE relief fund so
we're raising money currently if you're
interested in that you could go to
wicked good gaming com click on shop
it'll be it should be the first design
that pops up yeah
we're also hosting a Valor
tournament oh I'm Saturday I think
that'll clean up you gonna get there
shoutcasting so he gonna be late yeah
yeah I think we mean I'm looking back oh
okay we don't get clean for this but
yeah check that out anything else
hmm trying to think I'm trying to think
no I mean thanks for having us on always
a pleasure always miss Bert always a
Mudge man we got to get me some check
we're still gonna continue all but I
wanted to give you guys the proper
respect on your exits absolutely I'm
saying I'll see you guys soon
no I gotta go gotta go full blind in the
top five of all time I can't have
anything salute back let's see yeah we
have Aaron Johnson with the flat a
superset according to the rumor middle
Xbox does have a hardware and features
event is June as well yeah heard that is
and then we got kissable Oh solo final
super chat should Xbox be worried about
Deb's overhyping PlayStation 5
architecture on both sides right because
the scorned Dev says her and stuff and
then again it it's scorn so you have to
take it with a little bit of a grain of
salt same way whatever PS dev is saying
whatever you know you take it with a
grain you make your own come to your own
conclusions no doubt again I believe
kiss wool back to back my brother
possibly check Xbox has been announcing
new games for series X since June 2019
why people ask about new games now that
Xbox broke snooze with its new upgraded
backward compatibility plans I mean it's
a question and I think again I think it
comes down to some people are concerned
about timing versus some people you know
I'm just concerned about having the
information and transparency you know
look they've got job to do we definitely
know that not everyone like the timing
of it and then some people fellow I
don't that what's your Menace value you
know it's up to them to convince people
with the first party showing and then I
guess that might stop the noise so
Smitty Smith till I see a give it a
salute to Wicca good on the way out the
book of X you already know yeah and then
I know you want to get Mariano Mariano
pump out the fire Thank You Lourdes hey
Lou
and it is real it's always appreciating
then statement during these times
everyone stay safe like what the hell we
got rangy for someone he's going into
the next generation with the success of
the ps4 exclusives will Sony purchase
ITN in case flat gaming studio let me
get caught with the $2 super chat where
he says sob x4 Xbox backpack with
compatib for Xbox 360 was a blog post
that's what I'm saying
ghost was a blog then they then they put
out the big thing that we it wasn't even
big it became big because of the way
people reacted to it about thousands of
games but block and how they detailed
what it was that's fine that's fine
that's fine not high I think it's why I
think the timing is ill by the timing of
the blog post is a solid item not the
timing of the blog put that information
out articles about it right I'm not the
only one I call Spanish because we all
Thursday I hope when the whole internet
explained that third party reveal was in
and you know
you know what you know what I never
really with the Krauts for a month to
see game literally speed I'm just good
to go half hour ago I know you had to go
technically she Betty but listen yes it
was to reveal went down you don't say I
watched it you never say I'm not gonna
spoil too much but I thought it was
visceral I thought it was really cool
you don't say it homegirl really this
room this is a role yes really versatile
really cool I love the agility you know
I'm saying of her you know take a
comparison to home oh boy and um yeah
man look um
the dog is it hard I like that the whole
they got that you can track your set now
you know I'm saying with the whole joint
you know we got the factions and stuff
like that different yeah what's question
my question is are you and there was the
old question that they said before but
after seeing this reveal yeah I really
didn't watch too much soap but I had to
yeah
are they being beautiful brutality sake
like no argument early on you remember
when they showed when they showed it off
like you know whatever last year
whatever they were when they were like
is this we know that the argument was
right we know the type of world this is
right right yeah this is the world where
brutal for brutality say kind of it
could be the norm day in and day out so
you know it depends on what side of the
fence you fall all other concern things
like gratuitous or not I think for the
world that they think that if you play
part one you know where that world is
and you see the end of part one you
realize that it's only gonna get worse
kind of so I could definitely see you
think were two of these things because
that's just the norm of things in that
world it's over the top but it's gonna
depend on how they put the story around
it right and how it's gonna wrap around
right yeah so I mean to me I don't worry
about the violence and again
because I you know what I know Naughty
Dog has only gotten better at their
craft especially about you when it comes
to these characters and so I don't know
what I I think if you have an issue
would be true this violence in general
you're not you're probably not gonna
this is not the game you be game for you
yeah and then just put it real quick
obviously you know obviously hurt the
leaks and all that stuff but one
information I did come out that the
pre-orders were kind of doing is good
experiment so they look again we gotta
wait it's good though yeah I still on
track you know I know a lot of people
talk about stuff with hyperbole with
that but look I thought it'd look good
you know I've been replaying one just to
get ready for it and that's all I got on
it but I go a lot oh I still got go
sushi box a bobble I go for that too
sweet cherry blossom so a dick that's
just me I could I didn't watch it at all
I was like blackout I don't want to see
any event the game if it was a few
months out I might have been tempted to
watch it but we got a month so less than
a month so I wait you know I'm super
excited for it like I said I think I I'm
one of those people those in the camp
that felt they didn't need to have a
sequel but if for another girl to come
out and do it and they could easily walk
away from me like oh this is the story I
wanted to tell that's it yeah to finally
decide to come out and make this game
means that they they have a story that
they feel is worth telling so that
that's exciting to me I saw a couple of
things of it and I was always in a camp
that I thought the first one was like a
one-off
right yeah like it right felt like it
especially with the DLC right it felt
like it was a one-off but then I saw
some things that lead led me to believe
that it wasn't completely closed off and
I needed some resolution with certain
characters storyline right and and I saw
that just that much because I stopped
watching yeah I didn't watch the whole
20 minutes whatever it was you know I
cut it probably after like five minutes
right um but I saw certain things and I
was like yes and then I already know I
mean cuz okay I'm not physically
purchasing these games from Sony this is
the first time I'm going to just you
know cuz I did Tekken digitally with
yeah and I think I did probably another
game digitally with them but I'm going
to purchase these games digitally
because these are the games I really
want on my playstation 5 going for I
wanted it next I feel you right I'm
gonna marry yeah yeah so if they happen
to do something like a boost mode or
whatever it does to it I definitely just
want them there because I think it was a
good game Jim Ryan actually said they
asked him about Last of Us right he said
he say he said it'll run smoothly on PSP
[Music]
you know me right now let's see what
happens but look man that's what I got
attic I don't know if you got your balls
off your beauty like you're eating and
doing your own show over there look man
this is going on three hours hungry
what's he tilted to the side he's ready
to go so look look at the pole with the
latest a soda info regarding PlayStation
believing in the idea of generations do
you agree with the sentiment that
PlayStation 5 should not be playable on
the price flex five games should not be
playable on the ps4 opposed to Microsoft
going with a more PC like approach the
choices are a yes Sony is focusing on
the next gen it's the correct approach
be no Xbox cross-gen does not limit devs
tapping into the power or C I don't care
if these consoles still ain't hitting 60
frames per second so we go get the
lowest I shot everybody who won't
participate we're gonna get about get
shots are wicked good game and brothers
man it was always a pleasure to have
them in there
let's get Lord addict up in the building
very reserved today except for when Bob
says things you didn't like but other
than that you will find aiwei could a
five people fight Jigga's go to what you
say you can find me on Twitter
Lord addict IOP you'll find me on
youtube a game
addict I want to thank you know the wiki
gaming people from coming through you
can also find these chips man these are
amazing
DeVito sponsorship always chips again
with the truck a head set on the back we
got a hold okay we go tell the readers
to put it in color you go Dorito look
man we gonna start look here's some
propel to the bank goes out to the video
you guys do it all you get the bike rack
joint you got that amazing [ __ ] we got I
mean we got a $20 super check from gamer
by choice great guys show I enjoyed
myself need to stop my season I'm gonna
have to do like a pole one week that's
like voting the Lord these guys a person
but therefore they also they absolutely
awesome it's funny because I you know I
they remind me of the guys I hung out
with when I was in school in Boston yeah
we're down the earth guys it's fun to
chill out with cool people trying to do
stuff for the community so if you
haven't followed them please follow
wicked good games yes
and if yeah for me you know I got a good
work so I'm gonna do that um and then on
top of that I'm gonna try to get get
into this Atlantis DLC I'm excited um
and Thursday's gonna Thursday go
cake is coffee ready for you
I'll order you right now this your first
lottery with us all be slipping anyway
quit so this because this is this is us
like this is uh it's us like oh these
are my brothers week over thank you for
yo and sometimes no but I don't want to
ever see you say that in the chat ever
again cooking with trucker I know we're
adding but if you wear the overalls are
you wearing a shirt underneath no there
won't be none of that going on
yep you get 300 likes in the next three
shows our the overall solo shot the Alec
soluti says solve be like the Lannisters
send their regards
no no I mean 300 every show oh dude hey
we got trying to get me over I love how
you decide set that one I still want you
or some overalls then I went hard from
both sides for us so - we don't catch it
especially go catch it is Thursday right
so you can't live in our rec yard Owen
Lord King fighting the good fight
spinning on his square telling people to
claim a side we're gonna pop you a
budgie what you got going - uh sir
oh you catch me on a kale wet catch me
at Twitter David OTW same
Xbox Live on PlayStation Network is the
Xbox 360 level 100 your shout out to my
witty good gaming brothers yeah Chris
wasn't here today that's my little too
rich man he had the world come as the
man made dr. Bob as my guy I'll just I'm
definitely gonna call him after the show
on Thursday I wanted these because I boy
I've collected these back from there is
a part of me I'm not gonna like it is a
photo feed that if they shuffle I want
to pay I would pay money to see your
reaction I would literally pay literally
I'm going to break the intimate man but
I feel King at stuff stored up or sold
in the 400 me fellas next next week well
this way technically you don't wanna be
if you go what behaviors but is bag you
get a bag holding this obviously no no
listen this is rolling into next Sunday
now oh yeah I'm going to say this if
everything transpires exactly how I know
it's gonna transpire on Thursday right
cuz I know how it's gonna go
and you guys are gonna head a sad clown
face the happy sad happy said Sunday mmm
the level of form mm-hmm that I'm going
to be no man with the guests that we
have liner and once we confirm yeah we
got some cookin one list of everybody
that's here mm-hmm
Oh God in there you you will not ever
want to miss
next Sunday yeah that's a fact hopefully
like I said we're gonna get jakes it but
hopefully we got some really cool things
planned for Sunday's gonna be hopefully
super lit stayed to about Thursday's the
immediate focus please tune in you can
say 4:00 p.m. Eastern attic we're gonna
do that giant bedding she'll be able to
make it hopefully and yeah it should be
the whole loads for the first hour solve
we'll be in the building live we'll have
to deal with solve it's gonna be lit we
can stand we got a deal with you now the
Lannisters are here we got a deal with
you
and you get to see live and direct may I
begin on a serious note man positive
times thank you thank you so much you're
awful rocket what else we try to just
kick your mind we know there's a lot of
negativity in the world right now but we
wanted you guys to come in it's a happy
zone a happy place
and really the love shown is just for
two hours oh my god oh my god get it
that was definitely a moment on these
movies like they gotta be short they
can't do that sweetie they do that it's
over but look everybody back enjoy your
Sunday we go here chat with this al Joe
love you guys please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]